Hi everybody, how was your day today? Are you asking us or the audience and you're expecting an answer from the audience? You know the audience is not mic'd. You got it. Sorry. Well no, I was asked, oh they're not? Since when do you call me and JB everybody? Yeah.
大家好，今天过得怎么样？你是问我们还是问观众，而且你期待观众回答吗？你知道观众没戴麦克风。你说得对。抱歉。好吧，不，我被问到了，哦，他们没戴吗？你从什么时候开始把我和JB叫作“大家”的？是啊。
No, I call you guys the audience. Because you think that's the only people listening to you is just us two? Yeah. You've got higher responsibilities in in that let's come with the good stuff Judging by this opening we're after it's gonna be a great smartless welcome to it I'm Sean. I'm Sean. I'm Sean. I'm Sean. I'm Sean.
不，我把你们叫作观众。因为你以为只有我们两个在听你说话吗？是啊。你肩负着更重要的责任，让我们聊点有意思的吧。从这个开场来看，我们正期待着，这会是一期很棒的《SmartLess》，欢迎收听。我是肖恩。我是肖恩。我是肖恩。我是肖恩。我是肖恩。
I'm Sean. I'm Sean. I'm Sean. I'm Sean. I'm Sean. I'm Sean. I'm Sean. I'm Sean.
我是肖恩。我是肖恩。我是肖恩。我是肖恩。我是肖恩。我是肖恩。我是肖恩。我是肖恩。
I'm Sean. I'm Sean. I'm Sean. I'm Sean. I'm Sean. I'm after that you got a diploma I heard that after they give you a diploma that they were stripped of their power was like a real on Is that an online universe? So I still wear my sash to bed once they did an assessment of your intellect They're like we gave this guy a fucking diploma Did you really go to ISU? I went to Illinois State University. Yes, the one of the greatest colleges ever. Okay Well, hang on. Let's quickly Google that
我是肖恩。我是肖恩。我是肖恩。我是肖恩。我是肖恩。在那之后你拿到了文凭，我听说他们给你文凭后，你的权力就被剥夺了，这就像是一个真正的……那是一个在线宇宙吗？所以我还是会穿着我的绶带睡觉，一旦他们评估了你的智力，他们就会说，我们竟然给了这家伙一张该死的文凭。你真的去过伊利诺伊州立大学吗？我去了伊利诺伊州立大学。是的，那是史上最伟大的大学之一。好吧，等等。让我们快速谷歌一下。
See I don't think you're gonna like first theater theater by the way, you know who went there me Jane Lynch Craig Robinson And I were music majors together. No, we I know we've had them We talked about for like half an hour. Hey Arnett, where'd you go to school? I didn't, I dropped out, man. No, but you did go. You went to boarding school. You know where I went? I went to fucking Hard Knocks, dude.
你看，我不认为你会喜欢……顺便说一下，戏剧，你知道谁去过那里吗？我、简·林奇、克雷格·罗宾逊。我们曾一起主修音乐。不，我们……我知道我们请过他们。我们聊了大概半小时。嘿，阿内特，你上哪所学校？我没上，我退学了，伙计。不，但你确实去了。你上了寄宿学校。你知道我去了哪吗？我去了该死的“硬敲学校”（Hard Knocks），伙计。
Oh, bro. The streets. The Hard Knock life with Annie? The streets of Toronto. Did you go, you went to- Excuse me. Excuse me. You went to additional voluntary school?
哦，兄弟。街头。和安妮一起的“硬敲生活”？多伦多的街头。你去了……你去了……打扰一下。打扰一下。你去了额外自愿学校？
I did for half a year. Half a year. I know, I love that you go to additional voluntary school? I did for half a year. I know, I love that you go on a voluntary school. No, actually I should revert that. Voluntary additional school. And I just didn't understand the concept of that. I now have an option to not go, so taking that option. Sure.
我去了半年。半年。我知道，我喜欢你说的“去额外自愿学校”？我去了半年。我知道，我喜欢你说的“去自愿学校”。不，其实我应该改口。自愿额外学校。我只是不理解那个概念。我现在可以选择不去，所以就选了那个选项。当然。
You want a good joke? Yeah, sure, love one ISU. Well, sure, just jump in. I didn't realize that you were grabbing the reins here. We were just merrily going down a path, but. Oh, let's talk more about your school. Let's just go fucking, okay. Let's talk more about your school.
你想听个好笑话吗？是啊，当然，我很想听一个。伊利诺伊州立大学。好吧，当然，直接说吧。我没意识到你在这里掌握着主动权。我们本来正愉快地走在路上，但是……哦，让我们多聊聊你的学校。让我们直接……好吧。让我们多聊聊你的学校。
I didn't come. No, let's not. Here we go, ready? The best gift I ever received was a broken drum. You can't beat it. Okay, that's not here. We go ready the best gift I ever received was a broken drum. You can't beat it Okay, that's all right, that's okay. He doesn't claim that these to be great jokes I got a couple laughs in the background there you should you should say do you want to hear a dad joke if you say? Ready for something good dad joke means it's not like the term dad joke I think that that's I think that's lazy to call it a dad joke.
我没来。不，别聊了。开始了，准备好了吗？我收到的最好的礼物是一个破鼓。你没法打它。好吧，那不是……开始了，准备好了吗？我收到的最好的礼物是一个破鼓。你没法打它。好吧，没关系，那没关系。他并不声称这些是伟大的笑话。我在背景里听到几声笑声，你应该……你应该说“你想听个冷笑话吗？”如果你说……准备好听点好的，冷笑话意味着它不像……“冷笑话”这个词，我觉得把这叫作冷笑话很懒。
How about bad joke? Just say bad joke so people aren't expecting to laugh. Or like a pun. That's okay to say. I got one more, you got one more. Are there any mom jokes? Here's a mom joke. What's faster, hot or cold?
叫“烂笑话”怎么样？就叫烂笑话，这样人们就不会期待发笑了。或者像双关语。那样说没问题。我还有一个，你还有一个。有“妈妈笑话”吗？这是一个妈妈笑话。什么更快，热还是冷？
Hot, you can always catch a cold. That's good, that's good. That's not bad. That's pretty good. I guarantee you at least one of our listeners will be using that today after they get out of their car or off their subway or done with their jog. It's fun.
热，因为你总是能“赶上”（catch）感冒。那很好，那很好。那还不赖。那相当不错。我保证我们至少有一位听众今天下车、下地铁或跑完步后会用这个。很有趣。
You're welcome. I love, just no, hang on Sean. I love Jason trying to imagine what regular people do. It's so fun. They get on the subway and then they go. And then they kiss their kids goodbye, walk out door, go to job. Say hi boss, office. Want to hear a joke. Oh dear. Want to hear a joke. At water cooler with me. I love Succession 2 and what are
不客气。我喜欢……不，等等，肖恩。我喜欢杰森试图想象普通人做什么。这太有趣了。他们坐上地铁，然后他们走。然后他们亲吻孩子告别，走出家门，去上班。跟老板说嗨，办公室。想听个笑话吗？哦，天哪。想听个笑话吗？在饮水机旁跟我说。我喜欢《继承之战》，还有你在看什么？
you watching? I'm also watching Succession. Are you watching it? I am also worried about saying that I don't like it to yours word. Do you're saying I do like it? I'm just all right the joke real real good opening pattern everybody did everybody sleep well. I slept really well Patters over let's get to our high-level guest. Okay, really good though Did you for the first actually that is worth itail. You wanna talk to us about your sleep? The guest is not gonna wait for your sleep report. Well it's very rare that he has good sleep.
我也在看《继承之战》。你在看吗？我也很担心说我不喜欢它，这会……你是说我喜欢它？我只是……好吧，这个笑话……非常好的开场模式，大家，大家睡得好吗？我睡得非常好。模式结束了，让我们进入我们的重量级嘉宾环节。好吧，真的很棒。你……为了第一次，这确实值得一说。你想跟我们聊聊你的睡眠吗？嘉宾可不会等你的睡眠报告。好吧，他能睡个好觉是非常罕见的。
Before we get into it, it is true, Sean, and I'm happy for you and there's nobody, we talk about it all the time. Sean, yesterday morning JB, Sean, I said to him, hey you got a second, let me know when you got a second, like seven, I'm up at six, I said let me know when you got a second. It was like seven. got a second like seven. I'm up at six I said let me know when you got like seven. It was at seven He calls me and I go and I thought that he was back, you know
在我们开始之前，这是真的，肖恩，我为你感到高兴，没人……我们一直在谈论这个。肖恩，昨天早上JB，肖恩，我对他说，嘿，你有空吗，有空告诉我一声，大概七点，我六点就起了，我说有空告诉我一声。当时大概七点。有空告诉我一声，大概七点。我六点就起了，我说有空告诉我一声。当时是七点。他给我打电话，我去了，我以为他回来了，你知道……
As usual thing he wakes up in the middle night and then he goes back to bed at 630 until 10 is whatever. Yeah, he was up and he'd been up since 330 He's been on a bad run of not being able to sleep. So so I slept all through the night I got up to pee and I went right back to sleep Why do you think that is did you load up on a bunch of sugar before you went to bed? I did a little bit but because of Yesterday, I think that what wills talking about I think I ran myself around in circles like a little child Being up at 330 and then I just crashed and it made me sleep all night long was awesome
像往常一样，他半夜醒来，然后从6:30睡到10点，随便吧。是啊，他醒了，而且他从3:30就醒了。他最近睡眠状况很差。所以……我整晚都睡着了。我起来上厕所，然后又回去接着睡了。你觉得这是为什么？你睡前是不是摄入了很多糖分？我确实吃了一点，但因为昨天，我想这就是威尔说的，我想我像个小孩子一样把自己折腾得团团转，3:30就醒了，然后我就崩溃了，这让我整晚都睡得很香，太棒了。
You know what a fucking story It was awesome. You nap. What a fucking story. I'll nap like ten minutes. I'll nap like ten minutes. Anyway, so. Good that we stopped for that. You were right, Will.
你知道这算什么该死的故事吗？这太棒了。你小睡。这算什么该死的故事。我会小睡十分钟。我会小睡十分钟。总之，所以。很高兴我们停下来聊这个。你是对的，威尔。
Silly me. So today's guest is so immensely accomplished. We're gonna see David's face. What a fucking story. God, who else slept through the whole night? Make sure you call in. Our lines are open. And love to hear about it.
我真傻。所以今天的嘉宾成就极其卓越。我们要看到大卫的脸了。这算什么该死的故事。天哪，还有谁整晚都睡着了？一定要打进来。我们的热线是开通的。很想听听关于它的事。
So our next guest is so accomplished and so universally loved, okay? He's so accomplished and so universally loved. He's done everything. He's done television, film, theater. He's even got a Grammy, I believe. It's been comedy, it's been drama, it's been popcorn movies, it's been academy movies. I just don't know what else to say about this fella except he's a new friend.
所以我们的下一位嘉宾成就卓越，而且受到普遍喜爱，好吗？他成就卓越，受到普遍喜爱。他什么都做过。他做过电视、电影、戏剧。我相信他甚至还得过格莱美奖。有喜剧，有剧情片，有爆米花电影，有学院派电影。我不知道还能怎么评价这位伙计，除了他是一位新朋友。
Oh. Okay. Okay. We met online. And he is also a Capricorn. And no, he is a new friend that I'm very excited about. He swings a mean golf club. Oh, I thought you were gonna say both. The way that started was he swings. I know. I know. I was like, oh, what?
哦。好吧。好吧。我们在网上认识的。而且他也是摩羯座。不，他是我非常兴奋结识的一位新朋友。他挥动高尔夫球杆的样子很厉害。哦，我以为你要说两者。刚才那句话的开头是“他挥动……”。我知道。我知道。我当时想，哦，什么？
He'll take you where you want to go on the weekends, okay? Well, that's what I'm saying. But listen, I love him. He's here. Very kind of him to say yes, because this is a big shot. Ladies and gentlemen, Mr. Don Cheadle. Hello, Don. I love Don Cheadle. Hello, Don. Oh, I love Don Cheadle. People.
周末他会带你去你想去的地方，好吗？好吧，我就是这个意思。但听着，我爱他。他在这儿。他能答应真是太好了，因为这是一位大人物。女士们，先生们，唐·钱德尔先生。你好，唐。我爱唐·钱德尔。你好，唐。哦，我爱唐·钱德尔。各位。
What's happening? Good morning. Don. Don Cheadle's done everything. You know what I was trying to remember, Don? What is that great nickname that you were given because you're so smooth? I couldn't remember it. You told me this on the golf course.
怎么了？早上好，唐。唐·钱德尔什么都做过。你知道我刚才在努力回忆什么吗，唐？那个因为你太潇洒而被赋予的伟大绰号是什么？我记不起来了。你在高尔夫球场上告诉过我。
I think Kelly Slater said that was very Don Shallant. Yeah! Don Shallant! Is that a new nickname? That's really clever. I'm trying to put it out there. I was going to try to trademark it, but I was unsuccessful. Don Shallant is out there now, just FYI. It's fully out there, and if you happen to run into Don Chilon
我想凯利·斯莱特说那非常“Don Shallant”（潇洒）。是啊！Don Shallant！那是个新绰号吗？那真的很聪明。我正试图推广它。我本来想注册商标，但没成功。Don Shallant现在已经传开了，顺便说一下。它已经完全传开了，如果你碰巧在街上遇到唐·钱德尔……
in the streets, just immediately, Don Chilon. Yeah. Let him know. Mr. Chilon. You can single gun it or double gun it. I don't know. Wow. OK.
直接叫他Don Shallant。是啊。让他知道。钱德尔先生。你可以单手比枪或双手比枪。我不知道。哇。好吧。
Don. Don Chilon, hi. Good morning. What's up gang? I love Don Cheadle. You know, the team was like, you've gotta do these guys' podcasts. You're gonna love them. I love all of you individually and collectively. Not as much when I sat through the banter. The early banter. It's like, remember the joy
唐。Don Shallant，你好。早上好。怎么了，伙计们？我爱唐·钱德尔。你知道，团队当时说，你一定要上这些家伙的播客。你会爱上他们的。我爱你们所有人，无论是单独还是集体。当我听完那些闲聊时，就没那么爱了。早期的闲聊。就像，记得那种快乐吗……
that Regis and Kathie Lee used to give you with that first 10 minutes of coffee powder? Right? Yeah. the early banter. It's like, remember the joy that Regis and Kathie Lee used to give you with that first 10 minutes of coffee pattern. That's what we're reaching for, Don. You know, we're on our way. It was a strong six minutes. Don, where are we finding you right now?
里吉斯和凯西·李在咖啡节目的前十分钟带给你的那种快乐吗？对吧？是啊。早期的闲聊。就像，记得里吉斯和凯西·李在咖啡节目的前十分钟带给你的那种快乐吗？唐，我们正在追求那个。你知道，我们正在路上。那六分钟很强。唐，我们现在在哪能找到你？
Because, and the reason I ask is, because you look like you're either coming from or going to the golf course because you're wearing a zip-up, but I want to say, which is surprising, because you are such, you're so busy, and rightfully so, because you're always, you fit in that category for me too, of people who are always good no matter what the project is. You're so consistently awesome all the time.
因为，我问的原因是，因为你看起来要么是从高尔夫球场来，要么是要去高尔夫球场，因为你穿着拉链衫，但我想说，这很令人惊讶，因为你太……你太忙了，而且理应如此，因为你总是……你对我来说也属于那一类人，无论什么项目，总是表现得很好。你一直都非常出色。
In your work. Wait until you see this one. Who's gonna take that down? I don't know. Quick. You know what, you know what I just watched just last week, not even knowing obviously that we were gonna be on, because you're Jason's guest, we watched Mission to Mars.
在你的工作中。等着看这一部吧。谁能打败它？我不知道。快。你知道我上周刚看了什么吗，显然不知道我们要上节目，因为你是杰森的嘉宾，我们看了《火星任务》。
I was in that. And I was like, there's Don, again, and you're brilliant in it. Always. Always brilliant. Because you know I'll watch anything sci-fi. I am picking up on surprise in Sean's voice though. Right, when he says, and you're brilliant.
我演了那部戏。我当时想，唐又在那儿了，你在里面表现得很棒。总是。总是很棒。因为你知道我会看任何科幻片。不过我确实察觉到肖恩声音里的惊讶了。对吧，当他说“而且你表现得很棒”的时候。
It was like, you were pretty good. No, I meant to Will's point, you're a bold. I didn't know you were an actor. You're a. And that you could grow facial hair. I thought it was only Jason who could grow facial hair. This is not really facial hair, this is disgusting. No, it was great.
听起来像是，你还不错。不，我是指威尔的观点，你是一个……我不知道你是个演员。你是一个……而且你还能留胡子。我以为只有杰森能留胡子。这其实不是胡子，这很恶心。不，这很棒。
Well, so Don. I'm in Atlanta, Will, to answer your question, I is disgusting. No, it was great. So, Don. I'm in Atlanta, Will, to answer your question, I'm in Atlanta. You're in Atlanta. And what's happening there in Atlanta? Working on something, no doubt? I'm working on something, it's a project called Fight Night. And I am in this wonderful project
好吧，所以唐。我在亚特兰大，威尔，回答你的问题，我……这很恶心。不，这很棒。所以，唐。我在亚特兰大，威尔，回答你的问题，我在亚特兰大。你在亚特兰大。亚特兰大那边发生了什么？毫无疑问是在拍什么东西吧？我正在拍东西，是一个叫《搏击之夜》（Fight Night）的项目。我正在这个精彩的项目里……
with who you guys had on the show, Kevin Hart. Sam Jackson. Taraji Henson, Terrence Howard. Wow. Yeah, it should be, I'm looking forward to it. I just, I've shot one day, so I'm looking forward to this. You can still be fired. They can still easily reshoot one day before. Yeah, it's early enough. Yeah, so watch it.
和你们节目请过的凯文·哈特一起。萨缪尔·杰克逊。塔拉吉·汉森，泰伦斯·霍华德。哇。是啊，应该会……我很期待。我只是……我才拍了一天，所以我很期待这个。你还是可能被解雇的。他们还是可以轻易重拍一天的。是啊，还早呢。是啊，所以看着吧。
I've been replaced before. It wouldn't be the first time. enough. Yeah, so watch it. I've been replaced before. It wouldn't be the first time. Have you? No. Have you? I've been replaced before. I have. I didn't mean to bring up something pink.
我以前被替换过。这不会是第一次。还早呢。是啊，所以看着吧。我以前被替换过。这不会是第一次。你有过吗？没有。你有过吗？我以前被替换过。我有过。我不是故意要提起什么伤心事。
Oh wait, I love that Don's like, no. I haven't, sorry, I was just kidding. Of course not. Mine was a cruelest though, because I worked my nards off on this pilot, we shot the pilot, it went well, so I thought, and then like a couple of days before the big announcements happen
哦等等，我喜欢唐说“不”。我没有，抱歉，我只是开个玩笑。当然没有。不过我的那次是最残酷的，因为我在这个试播集里拼了老命，我们拍了试播集，进展顺利，所以我以为……然后就在大公告发布前几天……
about whether pilots are gonna get picked up to go to series, I get a call from my agent saying, you are going to, good news, bad news, good news is the show got picked up. And I said, unbelievable, he, goes here, let me finish. The bad news is that they're gonna go a different direction with your character. I said, okay.
关于试播集是否会被预订成系列剧，我接到经纪人的电话说，你要……好消息，坏消息，好消息是剧集被预订了。我说，难以置信，他说，等等，让我说完。坏消息是他们打算换个方向处理你的角色。我说，好吧。
Two days later, found out they're actually not picking up the show. So could you, I mean, this is like the worst 48 hours. Right? So good, bad, good. Good, bad, good, I agree with Don. I could have been spared all of it by just them saying, well, we're not picking up the show.
两天后，发现他们其实根本没预订这部剧。所以你能……我的意思是，这就像是最糟糕的48小时。对吧？所以好、坏、好。好、坏、好，我同意唐的说法。如果他们直接说“我们不预订这部剧”，我就可以免受这一切了。
Basically, we're all fired, you know? Are you still with this agent? Yeah, that's gonna be the story. Yeah, exactly. No, no, no. That's three or four ago. But it's good to know, I like it is personal a little bit because they were like, hey,
基本上，我们都被解雇了，你知道吗？你还在用这个经纪人吗？是啊，那会是个故事。是啊，没错。不，不，不。那是三四年前的事了。但很高兴知道，我喜欢它有点私人化，因为他们当时说，嘿……
we know the show's not getting picked up, but let's let Bateman know that even if it did, he wasn't coming away. Yeah. In the event that this is going forward, not you. I've been fired too. I got fired off a pilot that went to series the year before we started Arrested Development. Oh, God bless. And had I not been, I would have been stuck on that show.
我们知道这部剧不会被预订，但让我们告诉贝特曼，即使预订了，他也不会参与。是啊。如果这事继续下去，不是你。我也被解雇过。我在《发展受阻》开始前一年被一部试播集解雇了。哦，上帝保佑。如果我没被解雇，我就被困在那部剧里了。
Don, wait a second. so you're in Atlanta, you're doing this thing with Sam Jackson. Are you potentially playing golf with Sam today? You know, Sam has been on IR for a minute. I hope he comes off because I would love to. We used to play a lot, but he's nursing an injury or two. Fingers crossed. How's his game?
唐，等一下。所以你在亚特兰大，你在和萨缪尔·杰克逊拍那个东西。你今天有可能和萨缪尔打高尔夫吗？你知道，萨缪尔已经伤停一会儿了。我希望他能复出，因为我很想去。我们以前常打，但他正在养伤。祈祷吧。他的水平怎么样？
Sam was like a four. What? Wow. Yeah. Damn it. Wow. There's all these people, the game is just so easy to so many people.
萨缪尔大概是4杆水平。什么？哇。该死。哇。有这么多人，这项运动对这么多人来说都太容易了。
Well, you know, Sam, famously, you know, whenever he would get a gig, a part of his contract was they had to get him a membership to whatever local course there was because he's such a freak about it. So he... Oh really, no shit? Yeah, he played everywhere.
好吧，你知道，萨缪尔，众所周知，你知道，每当他接到工作，他合同的一部分就是他们必须给他当地任何球场的会员资格，因为他对此太疯狂了。所以他……哦真的吗，没开玩笑？是啊，他到处打。
I was like, you can do that? Sam also was, you know, Mr. if you force me, you're bringing me $900 in cash in an envelope the next day, like a drug deal. I was like, this dude's my hero. Yeah, that's always the one. By the way, Jason, you could, Jason, right now, you see he looked down, he's got,
我当时想，你还能那样做？萨缪尔也是，你知道，那种“如果你强迫我”先生，第二天你得用信封给我900美元现金，就像毒品交易一样。我当时想，这家伙是我的英雄。是啊，总是那样。顺便说一下，杰森，你可以……杰森，现在，你看他低头了，他……
he's just gone on his phone, you know, speed dialed the CAA right now. He's like, what the fuck? What are you guys? I'm about 12 country clubs short, damn it. Yeah. All right, now how do you like Atlanta? I've worked there a lot, and I always thought
他刚才在看手机，你知道，现在正给CAA拨快速拨号呢。他心想，搞什么鬼？你们这些家伙在干什么？我离12个乡村俱乐部还差得远呢，该死。是啊。好吧，现在你觉得亚特兰大怎么样？我在那里工作过很多次，我一直以为……
that it was not gonna be a place for me, and every time I work there, I just love it more and more and more. Do you enjoy yourself there? You've worked there a bunch, yes? I've worked here a bunch because a lot of the Marvel stuff was here. Right. Oh, right.
那不会是我待的地方，但每次我在那里工作，我就越来越喜欢它。你在那里玩得开心吗？你在那里工作过很多次，对吧？我在那里工作过很多次，因为很多漫威的东西都在那儿。对。哦，对。
And I've kinda been around it a little bit more, but this is probably the longest stretch that I'm gonna be here, so I'm looking forward to like getting up to the mountains and going to the lakes and just checking it all out. So I did a movie there a long time ago in Atlanta during the summer. Did you guys shoot all those Marvel movies
而且我对此稍微熟悉了一点，但这可能是我待的最长的一段时间，所以我很期待去山上，去湖边，看看这一切。所以我很久以前在亚特兰大拍过一部电影，是在夏天。你们是不是在夏天拍了所有那些漫威电影……
in the summertime because you can't breathe, it's so hot. Hot Atlanta, hot Atlanta. Yeah, and how do you, you're in those costumes and running around in that heat, is that what it is? And you're in space. Yeah, I mean I think that was the... Oh, there's a callback. I have a callback. Good one. No, but I mean, isn't that brutal?
因为你没法呼吸，太热了。炎热的亚特兰大，炎热的亚特兰大。是啊，你怎么……你穿着那些戏服在那种高温下跑来跑去，是这样吗？而且你在太空里。是啊，我的意思是我想那是……哦，有个呼应。我有个呼应。好样的。不，但我的意思是，那不是很残酷吗？
Yeah, it's brutal. I mean, I'm from Kansas City, Missouri, where 98 degrees and 98% humidity, so I was born for this, you know? But yeah, it's not fun. But right now, it's very cold, actually. It's very brief at night. I like it too.
是啊，很残酷。我的意思是，我来自密苏里州堪萨斯城，那里有98度的高温和98%的湿度，所以我天生就是为了这个，你知道吗？但确实，那不好玩。但现在，其实很冷。晚上很短暂。我也喜欢它。
I like JB. I spent the last few years about, last year I spent six months, I think, almost in Atlanta. And I really liked it. I really liked the people. Once you find a kind of a good zone where you can find your stuff and whatever, I liked it a lot.
我喜欢JB。过去几年里，去年我大概有六个月，我想，几乎都在亚特兰大。我真的很喜欢它。我真的很喜欢那里的人。一旦你找到了一个好的区域，你可以找到你的东西之类的，我就很喜欢它。
You gotta find a zone. But I was down in like, I was down like right near sort of little five points like all in there like that's where I was staying. It was awesome. A lot of great like restaurants and you know. Okay. Okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, um. Jason, have you had enough?
你得找到一个区域。但我当时在……我当时就在像“小五点”（Little Five Points）附近，就在那儿，我住在那儿。那太棒了。有很多很棒的餐馆，你知道。好吧。好吧。是啊，是啊，是啊。所以，嗯。杰森，你受够了吗？
Yeah, that's it. You opened it. It's like, fuck. You opened it. You opened it. This is like a, this is like the fucking court case. How was your s- Good sleep last night, Don? You know, what's hilarious when Sean was talking about that is I was very jealous because I did not sleep well last night. That's what I'm saying.
是啊，就这样。你打开了话匣子。就像，该死。你打开了话匣子。你打开了话匣子。这就像一个……这就像该死的法庭案件。昨晚睡得好吗，唐？你知道，肖恩谈论那个的时候很搞笑，因为我很嫉妒，因为我昨晚没睡好。我就是这个意思。
The fucking worst episode we've ever recorded. Right, we're right, we're 17 minutes into the work. From what I did, from what Sean, who's fault is it? No, no, it's all my fault, all my fault. I'm talking about fucking Atlanta, we're talking about the weather, we're talking about sleep. It's like, let's get to something hard hitting.
我们录过的最糟糕的一集。对，我们才录了17分钟。从我做的来看，从肖恩来看，是谁的错？不，不，全是我的错，全是我的错。我在谈论该死的亚特兰大，我们在谈论天气，我们在谈论睡眠。就像，让我们聊点硬核的东西吧。
Now somebody told me the other day that Kansas City... Oh, here we go. Kansas City is actually split right down the middle, the border between Kansas and Missouri. You still don't have it, J.B. You still don't have it. No?
刚才有人告诉我，堪萨斯城……哦，开始了。堪萨斯城其实是从中间一分为二的，是堪萨斯州和密苏里州的边界。你还是没搞明白，JB。你还是没搞明白。没有吗？
You still haven't got it. That's a whiff. No. Help me, people. No, no, no. There's one in Kansas and there's a Kansas City and Missouri. They're two different... I mean, they're close.
你还是没搞懂。那是个失误。没有。帮帮我，各位。不，不，不。有一个在堪萨斯州，还有一个堪萨斯城在密苏里州。它们是两个不同的……我的意思是，它们很近。
Wait, there's two different places called Kansas City. Oh my God. No, honestly. I know. Don's about to leave. Don, this is every day, by the way. This is how it goes. 54 years old and this is... I'm just now's about to leave. Don, this is every day, by the way. This is how it goes. 54 years old, and this is, I'm just now getting clarity on this.
等等，有两个不同的地方叫堪萨斯城。哦，天哪。不，说真的。我知道。唐快要走了。唐，顺便说一下，这每天都发生。事情就是这样。54岁了，这……我只是……唐快要走了。唐，顺便说一下，这每天都发生。事情就是这样。54岁了，这……我只是现在才搞清楚。
Let's do it publicly. There are two places called Kansas City, one's in Missouri, one's in Kansas? Yeah. Correct. Now which one's got the Chiefs? There is a border. Which one's got the Royals? Missouri. Missouri.
让我们公开做吧。有两个地方叫堪萨斯城，一个在密苏里州，一个在堪萨斯州？是啊。正确。现在哪个有酋长队？有一个边界。哪个有皇家队？密苏里州。密苏里州。
Missouri's got what? Let me just say this. Don, take a look at JB's face. JB walked on through the gummy routine. This is gonna explain a lot. Walk him through the timing and the amount. Guys, I'm still up. I'm still up from last night's chew.
密苏里州有什么？让我说这个。唐，看看JB的脸。JB刚才经历了软糖程序。这会解释很多。带他过一遍时间和剂量。伙计们，我还没睡。我还在昨晚那颗软糖的劲儿里。
No, now, okay, well then. We talked about this a little bit on the golf course. I don't remember. I don't know if you remember. I'm sure you don't remember, because your gummy program. No, no, never when I'm golfing. Golfing's serious business.
不，现在，好吧，那……我们在高尔夫球场上聊过这个。我不记得了。我不知道你记不记得。我肯定你不记得，因为你的软糖计划。不，不，我打高尔夫时从不吃。打高尔夫是严肃的事。
You said that. Now wait a second. But what sports team does Kansas City, Kansas have? The Royals? He's still, he's here. Is it the Royals? It's crazy. No, no, honestly.
你那么说过。现在等一下。但堪萨斯州堪萨斯城有什么运动队？皇家队？他还在，他在这儿。是皇家队吗？这太疯狂了。不，不，说真的。
Is it the Royals? Are in Kansas City? No, that's also Missouri. Do you want to ask Siri? Do we want to just ask, go to like the interwebs? So Kansas City, Kansas has nothing, is that correct? Yeah. No sports teams, no professional sports teams.
是皇家队吗？在堪萨斯城？不，那也是密苏里州。你想问Siri吗？我们要不要直接问，去互联网上查查？所以堪萨斯州堪萨斯城什么都没有，对吗？是啊。没有运动队，没有职业运动队。
Yeah, man. I'll let it rest now. Let's just look it up. Okay. And then I'm going to be in no time. Honestly, honestly, you might be right. Look, they're all looking it up, America. I've never looked into it this deeply.
是啊，伙计。我现在让它过去吧。让我们查查。好吧。然后我很快就会……说真的，说真的，你可能是对的。看，他们都在查，美国。我从来没这么深入地研究过。
You might be absolutely right. I just know they have always claimed the Chiefs. No, he's not right. He's not right. No, you're right. Kansas City, Kansas has the Royals. Are there any sports teams in Kansas City Kansas? I'm so sorry America.
你可能是绝对正确的。我只知道他们一直声称拥有酋长队。不，他不对。他不对。不，你是对的。堪萨斯州堪萨斯城有皇家队。堪萨斯州堪萨斯城有任何运动队吗？我很抱歉，美国。
And specifically... Kansas City has had teams in all five of the major professional sports leagues. Three major leagues remain today. Is that Missouri or is that Kansas? That's Kansas City Kansas. Okay. Wait, who's in Kansas City Kansas? I don't know.
具体来说……堪萨斯城在所有五大职业体育联盟中都有过球队。今天还剩下三个大联盟。那是密苏里州还是堪萨斯州？那是堪萨斯州堪萨斯城。好吧。等等，谁在堪萨斯州堪萨斯城？我不知道。
Yeah, I don't know. Boy, this is again... No, this is Kansas City. We're gonna pick this up. Hey Don, how'd you get started in the business? Yeah, no. I't know. Yeah, I don't know. Boy, this is, again, we're gonna pick this up. Hey Don, how'd you get started in the business? No, I wanna know. JB, fuck you, you have, you're... I wanna know that.
是啊，我不知道。天哪，这又是……不，这是堪萨斯城。我们要接着聊这个。嘿唐，你是怎么入行的？是啊，不。我不知道。是啊，我不知道。天哪，这又是……我们要接着聊这个。嘿唐，你是怎么入行的？不，我想知道。JB，去你的，你有……我想知道那个。
I was in a little porn called Don Chalontes. And... No, I do wanna know because to me, I've seen you in so many things, and like Will said, always brilliant. Like, to me, you were born on screen. Like, I don't know anything about you other than the- I was born on screen.
我当时在一部叫《Don Chalontes》的小色情片里。而且……不，我确实想知道，因为对我来说，我在很多东西里都见过你，就像威尔说的，总是很出色。对我来说，你就像是为屏幕而生的。就像，除了……我不知道关于你的任何事，除了……我是为屏幕而生的。
Yeah. Other than we run into each other a few times and had lovely conversations, but tell me, how did you get, like, you were in theater in high school? Well, sidebar, we almost, we played around with doing a movie together at one point. I remember. I don't know if you ever got that off.
是啊。除了我们偶尔碰面，聊得很开心之外，告诉我，你是怎么……就像，你高中时参加过戏剧社吗？好吧，题外话，我们有一次差点一起拍电影。我记得。我不知道你有没有搞定。
I did, it didn't do well. Did you get it off? Yeah, it didn't do well. But thank you for your consideration. Next subject, next subject. Way to dodge a bullet, Don. I was trying to give a compliment and went right in the trash bin.
我搞定了，但表现不好。你搞定了吗？是啊，表现不好。但谢谢你的考虑。下一个话题，下一个话题。躲过一劫啊，唐。我本来想夸你，结果直接进了垃圾桶。
You ducked one there. No, but were you interested in high school? Like how early did you get the bug? So I kind of got the early acting bug. I think I was in sixth grade. I was Templeton the Rat in a production of Charlotte's Web that was written about extensively in the Denver, Colorado periodicals.
你躲过了一次。不，但你高中时感兴趣吗？你是多早之前有的这个念头？所以我很早就有了演戏的念头。我想我是在六年级。我在《夏洛的网》的制作中演了坦普尔顿老鼠，那部戏在丹佛、科罗拉多的期刊上被广泛报道。
You can look it up, I'm sure it's still there. Sure, no, I'm not saying. Templeton the Rat. And I was single about. I'm sure it's still there. Sure, no. I'm not saying the tempo's in the rat. I'm just saying I was singled out. So, Matt. The standout was the rat. Yeah. And when Cheetal hits the stage, hold on to your... Yeah. So I did that, but I was also doing music kind of at the same time.
你可以查一下，我肯定它还在那儿。当然，不，我不是说……坦普尔顿老鼠。而且我被单独……我肯定它还在那儿。当然，不。我不是说坦普尔顿老鼠。我只是说我被特别提到了。所以，马特。那个亮点就是那只老鼠。是啊。当钱德尔登上舞台时，抓紧你的……是啊。所以我做了那个，但我同时也做音乐。
That's when I got involved in playing my saxophone and instrumental jazz. So I was on these two tracks of really studying music. And when I went to high school, I had a great acting coach, a great acting teacher, a great drama class. And I was in a really good jazz band. So I was on these two tracks. And then I graduated from high school.
那是我开始参与吹萨克斯和器乐爵士乐的时候。所以我当时在两条轨道上，真正地学习音乐。当我上高中时，我有一位很棒的表演教练，一位很棒的戏剧老师，一个很棒的戏剧班。而且我参加了一个非常好的爵士乐队。所以我当时在两条轨道上。然后我高中毕业了。
I had applied for both things, to go into music, to go into vocal jazz, to go into instrumental jazz, and also to study acting, theater acting. And I got some scholarship money from a bunch of different places. And I kind of made- For acting or music or both?
我两样都申请了，去学音乐，去学声乐爵士，去学器乐爵士，也去学表演，戏剧表演。我从很多不同的地方得到了一些奖学金。我有点……是为了表演还是音乐，还是两者？
Both, I had both. But I kind of made not only a weather choice, but I think I made a choice based on what I believed I was going to be able to actually do. Because I grew up with musicians now who are like professional musicians and who are hugely successful and incredible.
两者，我都有。但我做出的选择不仅是基于天气，我想我做出的选择是基于我相信我实际上能做什么。因为我从小就和音乐家一起长大，他们现在是职业音乐家，而且非常成功，令人难以置信。
And I knew what it was gonna take to actually be able to do that. go down that road and shedding and learning theory and doing all those things that I was like, I know I'm not going to do that. And I think I'm probably gonna spend my time more being out of the house, being with other people and pursuing acting and I loved it equally, so I kind of went up that road.
我知道要真正做到这一点需要什么。走那条路，练习，学习理论，做所有那些事情，我当时想，我知道我不会做那个。而且我想我可能会花更多时间在户外，和别人在一起，追求表演，我同样热爱它，所以我选择了那条路。
But yeah, there's definitely science and math to music that you have to want to. And I think it kind of, I was intimidated by it a little bit, to be honest. I think I was a little, you know, I'd gotten by, I had really good ear and I'd gotten by on really being able to hear music rather than understanding how it broke down.
但确实，音乐中有科学和数学，你必须想要去学。而且我想它有点……说实话，我有点被它吓到了。我想我有点，你知道，我混过来了，我有很好的听力，我靠能够听出音乐而不是理解它是如何分解的混过来了。
And I was kind of wide-eyed when it would, when I'd get into the weeds on that so I get that like I kind of ran to something that I felt more comfortable with but it's funny that the music has kind of come back around and that's become a bigger part of my career now too. But Don did you ever and Sean forgive me for taking your question but did you ever think about you know kind of like when that when that guy dropped the the chocolate in the in the tub of peanut butter and they came up with the Reese's did you ever think of taking the music
当我深入研究那个时，我有点目瞪口呆，所以我明白这一点，就像我跑向了我感觉更舒服的东西，但有趣的是，音乐又回到了我的生活中，那现在也成了我职业生涯中更大的一部分。但唐，你有没有……肖恩，原谅我抢了你的问题……你有没有想过，你知道，就像那个人把巧克力掉进花生酱桶里，他们发明了瑞茜巧克力一样，你有没有想过把音乐……
and dumping that into the theater and going into musical theater, Sean? Five, six, seven, eight. Seven, eight. Did that ever, did you ever get into that stuff? Oh, he sure did. Let's talk about the Tonys, go ahead. Oh.
倒进戏剧里，去演音乐剧，肖恩？五、六、七、八。七、八。你有没有接触过那些东西？哦，他当然有。让我们聊聊托尼奖，继续吧。哦。
Well, I've never gotten one. No, but you produced something that's, yes. But I did produce the Tonys, Tony award-winning show called Strange Loop. Yes! Oh my God! That's right! With Barbara Whitman. Yes. Right? And she produced the play I just did. That's right. Yeah.
好吧，我从来没得过。不，但你制作了一些……是的。但我确实制作了托尼奖，获得托尼奖的剧目叫《奇异循环》（Strange Loop）。是的！哦，天哪！没错！和芭芭拉·惠特曼一起。是的。对吧？她制作了我刚演的那部戏。没错。是啊。
Congrats on that. Thank you. Thank you. Crazy. Great show. But did you yourself, were you yourself at like in high school or afterwards in college? Absolutely, yes. 100%. I mean, when I graduated high school, the choice I made was to go to, I came to California and I studied at California Institute of the Arts. And we, you know, did everything there. Musicals and dramas and classical pieces, we did everything. It was really a great experience for me and a place to be able to try everything
恭喜。谢谢。谢谢。疯狂。很棒的演出。但你自己，你自己在高中或大学之后……绝对，是的。100%。我的意思是，当我高中毕业时，我做出的选择是去……我来到加州，在加州艺术学院学习。我们在那儿什么都做。音乐剧、戏剧、古典作品，我们什么都做。那对我来说真的是一次很棒的经历，是一个可以尝试一切的地方……
and make a lot of mistakes and not get fired for it as a result. Get ready because I love horrible theater stories, things that go wrong, so just get one ready. Oh yeah, they're the best. Before we get to one of those, can you guys extend your tolerance for my lack of intelligence again it's worn pretty fit at this point it's true very yeah don't bring no if I'm on the border but to know and we will be right back
并犯很多错误，而且不会因此被解雇。准备好吧，因为我喜欢糟糕的戏剧故事，那些出错的事情，所以准备一个。哦，是的，它们是最好的。在我们聊到其中一个之前，你们能再次宽容我缺乏智力吗？这一点现在已经磨损得很厉害了，这是真的，非常……不，如果我在边界上，我知道，我们会马上回来。
thank you to fan duel for supporting this episode of smart less the NBA And we will be right back. will get $150 in bonus bets, win or lose, to use during the NBA playoffs. There's no better place to bet all the playoff action than America's number one sports book. Personally, I would bet on what are the odds of me making a peanut butter sandwich today, and guess what, I'm literally holding it in my hand as you speak, not even kidding. Listen.
感谢FanDuel支持本期《SmartLess》。NBA……我们会马上回来。将获得150美元的奖励投注，无论输赢，可在NBA季后赛期间使用。没有比美国第一体育博彩公司更好的地方来投注所有季后赛动作了。个人而言，我会投注我今天做花生酱三明治的几率是多少，你猜怎么着，我说话时手里正拿着它，一点没开玩笑。听着。
Just go to fanduel.com slash smart list to get started. FanDuel, official sports betting partner of the NBA. 21 plus exclusions apply, see show notes for full disclaimer. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. So guys, how's your social battery right now? My social battery is, I'm a tiny bit drained, but I still do it because I think it's important to stay connected and social with not only your old friends and family,
只需前往fanduel.com/smartless即可开始。FanDuel，NBA官方体育博彩合作伙伴。21岁以上，适用排除条款，查看节目说明获取完整免责声明。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。所以伙计们，你们现在的社交电量如何？我的社交电量，我有点耗尽了，但我还是会做，因为我认为与老朋友和家人保持联系和社交很重要……
but your new friends and family that you're just meeting now. It's important to keep the social battery going to keep our brains going. But when it gets a little drained, it's a good time to maybe talk about why and how much you're spreading yourself a little too thin, especially with social gatherings
还有你刚认识的新朋友和家人。保持社交电量以保持大脑运转很重要。但当它有点耗尽时，这是一个好时机，也许可以谈谈为什么以及你把自己分散得太薄了，特别是在社交聚会……
picking up after the winter, right? What's the right amount of socializing for you and how do you recharge? Maybe you thrive around people or maybe you need some more alone time. Therapy can give you the self-awareness to build a social life that doesn't drain your battery. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge.
在冬天之后开始增加，对吧？对你来说，合适的社交量是多少，你如何充电？也许你在人群中茁壮成长，或者也许你需要更多独处时间。治疗可以给你建立社交生活的自我意识，而不会耗尽你的电量。如果你正在考虑开始治疗，试试BetterHelp。它完全在线，设计得方便、灵活，适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持证治疗师匹配，并随时免费更换治疗师。
Find your social sweet spot with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlis today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp.com slash smartlis. Smartlis is supported in part by Delta Airlines. So I'm flying home today from New York to Los Angeles and I'm really excited and I know I'm excited because I'm looking forward to a real comfortable, memorable in-flight experience and I know I have gotten that before with Delta Airlines.
用BetterHelp找到你的社交甜点。今天访问betterhelp.com/smartless，首次月费可享10%优惠。那是betterhelp.com/smartless。《SmartLess》部分由达美航空支持。所以我今天从纽约飞回洛杉矶，我真的很兴奋，我知道我很兴奋，因为我期待着一次真正舒适、难忘的飞行体验，我知道我以前在达美航空有过这种体验。
The WiFi, the good food, the in-flight entertainment, it's all designed to make it great and it is. When you think about it, half the trips you take are trips home, right? That's why Delta Airlines tries to make you feel at home long before you even get there. Delta Airlines has created an industry-leading flying experience curated to fit your needs. They have implemented sustainable alternatives for in-flight dining like plant-based dishes, bamboo cutlery, and organic gluten-free nutrient-packed snacks. Aside from their tasty snacks, they have premium food
WiFi、美食、机上娱乐，一切都是为了让它变得很棒，而且确实如此。当你想到这一点时，你进行的一半旅行都是回家的旅行，对吧？这就是为什么达美航空试图让你在到达之前很久就感到宾至如归。达美航空创造了行业领先的飞行体验，旨在满足你的需求。他们为机上餐饮实施了可持续的替代方案，如植物性菜肴、竹制餐具和有机无麸质营养丰富的零食。除了美味的零食，他们还有优质的食物……
and beverage options to enjoy while you comb through their 1,000 hours of in-flight entertainment. And if you're a Sky Miles member, sit back and enjoy fast-free Delta Sync Wi-Fi on your trip. Delta Airlines believes you should feel at home, even if you're 30,000 feet above it. Learn more at delta.com. 30,000 feet above it. Learn more at delta.com.
和饮料选择，让你在浏览他们1000小时的机上娱乐节目时享用。如果你是“飞凡里程常客计划”（Sky Miles）会员，坐下来享受旅途中快速免费的Delta Sync WiFi。达美航空认为你应该感到宾至如归，即使你在30000英尺的高空。在delta.com了解更多。30000英尺的高空。在delta.com了解更多。
And now back to the show. So jazz, talk to me about jazz. Now I'm a big music fan and specifically classical music and so I feel like if I love classical music, I could really love jazz because it's a little easier to love. It's a little bit more toe-tappy. But I gotta understand it a little bit more.
现在回到节目。所以爵士乐，跟我聊聊爵士乐。我现在是一个大音乐迷，特别是古典音乐，所以我感觉如果我喜欢古典音乐，我真的可以喜欢爵士乐，因为它更容易喜欢。它更让人想跟着打拍子。但我得稍微多了解它一点。
And I'm hearing that jazz, its real appeal is knowing that for the most part, it's improvised. Is that correct or is it more traditionally written out in their sheet music? That is a component of it. And I think the umbrella of jazz under that are many, many subdivisions and categories. It's a huge sort of a blanket term, especially by now.
我听说爵士乐，它真正的吸引力在于知道在大多数情况下，它是即兴创作的。这是正确的吗，还是它在乐谱上更传统地写出来了？那是其中的一个组成部分。而且我认为爵士乐的伞下有许多许多细分和类别。这是一个巨大的笼统术语，特别是在现在。
If you think of somebody like Robert Glasper, who I won a Grammy with for producing the album miles ahead. Anyway. I'm sorry, your cough sounds terrible. Your cough sounds really bad. It's my second Grammy, sorry. You got a really terrible cough.
如果你想到像罗伯特·格拉斯珀（Robert Glasper）这样的人，我和他一起制作了专辑《Miles Ahead》，并因此获得了格莱美奖。总之。抱歉，你的咳嗽听起来很糟糕。你的咳嗽听起来真的很严重。这是我的第二个格莱美奖，抱歉。你咳嗽得很厉害。
Yeah, thanks Will. Let me get a little water for him. Wait, are you close to an EGOT? Two Grammys. Oh, now your throat's clear now. I'm gonna get that looked at. Okay, that's good now. You have, do you have a nomination, EGOT?
是啊，谢谢威尔。让我给他拿点水。等等，你离EGOT（艾美奖、格莱美奖、奥斯卡奖、托尼奖大满贯）很近吗？两个格莱美奖。哦，现在你的喉咙清了。我会去检查一下。好吧，现在好了。你有提名吗，EGOT？
I think you do. Yes? I have a nomination, EGOT, yes. Wow. But not, I don't have them all. That's pretty fucking good. Wow. But like Rob Glasper, you look at his music and he's, you know, he spans the globe of
我想你有。是的？我有提名，EGOT，是的。哇。但不是……我没有全部。那真是太该死的好。哇。但像罗伯·格拉斯珀，你看看他的音乐，他是，你知道，他跨越了全球……
what his musical knowledge is and his experience. And he does popular stuff, black radio, which is sort of, I think you would think of more as like R&B influenced, and then he does straight ahead, jazz and standards, and he does everything in between. So I think if you were to ask a musician like that what jazz is, or even if you were gonna go back and ask Miles Davis what jazz was, he hated that word.
他的音乐知识和经验。他做流行音乐，Black Radio，我认为你可能会认为它更像R&B影响，然后他做纯正的爵士乐和标准曲，他做介于两者之间的一切。所以我认为如果你问像那样的音乐家什么是爵士乐，或者即使你回去问迈尔斯·戴维斯什么是爵士乐，他讨厌那个词。
He was like, that's a word to box somebody in. You know, it's about good music, it's about social music. So I think there are different, like when I get in the car and you know, the driver taking you somewhere is like, let's put on some jazz and he puts on smooth jazz. It's like, I wanna shoot him. I hate it. Yeah, I'm the same.
他说，那只是个用来把人框住的词。你知道，这关乎好的音乐，关乎社会音乐。所以我认为有不同的情况，比如我上车时，司机带你去某处，他说，放点爵士乐吧，然后他放了轻爵士。我就想毙了他。我讨厌那个。是的，我也一样。
Don, you have to forgive Jason because they don't do explanations of jazz on the Hollywood Reporter homepage. So he wouldn't read it. Yeah, I'm the same. Don, you have to forgive Jason because they don't do explanations of jazz on the Hollywood Reporter homepage so that he wouldn't read it. But let me just say this, we did this bit in our show Flaked. Nothing, huh, okay. So where we did, this guy's getting ready
唐，你得原谅杰森，因为《好莱坞报道》主页上没有爵士乐的解释。所以他不会去读。是的，我也一样。唐，你得原谅杰森，因为《好莱坞报道》主页上没有爵士乐的解释，所以他不会去读。但让我说一句，我们在我们的剧《Flaked》里做过这个桥段。没什么反应，哈，好吧。我们做的是，这家伙正准备
to have this girl over for a date and then his buddy, suggests he put jazz on. And they look at each other and they're unsure and he goes, I'm not sure where I fall on jazz. And our joke was always that like, I can't figure out if it's cool to say I do like it or if it's cool to say I don't like it and I'm still trying to decide where I land on that. Me too.
邀请这个女孩来约会，然后他的哥们建议他放点爵士乐。他们面面相觑，拿不定主意，他说，我不确定我对爵士乐的看法。我们的笑话一直是，我搞不清楚说我喜欢爵士乐是不是很酷，或者说我不喜欢是不是很酷，我还在努力决定我的立场。我也是。
Like I just feel like, you know, everyone says you should go to New Orleans for the Jazz Festival or when you should listen to lots of. And that's a very specific kind of jazz. Yeah, I'm more like, I'm open to it if there's a melody that I can hum back, like a song. I'm not open to the. Fair enough, yeah, yeah. The jazz that's just people just playing.
就像我觉得，你知道，每个人都说你应该去新奥尔良参加爵士音乐节，或者你应该多听听。那是一种非常具体的爵士乐。是的，我更倾向于，如果有一段我能跟着哼的旋律，像一首歌，我能接受。我不接受那种……有道理，是的，是的。那种只是人们随便乱弹的爵士乐。
Sort of fusion-y, improvised fusion. Is that even me? Yeah, because I can't latch onto anything. You can't whack off to anything? What? What did he say? I love it all, because if you're really, you know, if you're... Jazz, you can whack too.
有点融合风格，即兴融合。那甚至算爵士吗？是的，因为我抓不住任何东西。你抓不住任何东西？什么？他说什么？我喜欢这一切，因为如果你真的，你知道，如果你是……爵士乐，你也可以抓得住。
Sorry. Jazz. No, latch onto. Grab your thing and have some fun. Yeah. J.B., you heard it too, right? I think I might have. So Don, so you're learning the saxophone at an early age.
抱歉。爵士乐。不，是抓住。抓住你的东西，玩得开心点。是的。J.B.，你也听到了，对吧？我想我可能听到了。那么唐，所以你很小的时候就开始学萨克斯了。
That gets you into music. Eventually you find an appreciation for Miles Davis, and then that project comes about. Was that a documentary that you produced or? No, no, no, no, a movie. A film, and you played him, yes? Yes. We're not good journalists.
那让你进入了音乐领域。最终你学会了欣赏迈尔斯·戴维斯，然后那个项目就出现了。那是你制作的纪录片吗？不，不，不，不，是一部电影。一部电影，你扮演了他，对吧？是的。我们不是好记者。
Brilliantly, and I remember you telling me when I ran into you, you were working on that. You were so great. Some nominations or even some wins for that, I believe. Well, that was the Grammy that we got for the soundtrack, which is really cool, that one we put together with Rob Glasper, he and I put that together. So that was really cool.
演得太棒了，我记得我遇到你时你告诉我，你正在做那个。你太棒了。我相信还获得了一些提名甚至奖项。嗯，那是我们为原声带获得的格莱美奖，真的很酷，那是我们和罗伯·格拉斯珀一起制作的，我和他一起完成的。所以那真的很酷。
But yeah, I think it's a big category. Talk about jokes on shows, we had one on Black Monday where I'm talking to, thank you very much, I'm talking to Regina Don, her name, the character's Don about it, and she goes, yeah, I can never get into jazz, it just always sounds like a bunch of instruments thrown down a flight of stairs.
但是是的，我认为这是一个很大的类别。说到节目里的笑话，我们在《黑色星期一》里有一个，我在和——非常感谢——我在和雷吉娜·唐谈论这件事，她的名字，角色的名字是唐，她说，是的，我永远无法喜欢上爵士乐，听起来就像一堆乐器从楼梯上扔下来一样。
Yeah. Now, in my incredible research, did you really work on The Fresh Prince? Funny enough, I did. I was on one of the first episodes of Fresh Prince, and I have a funny pilot firing story too about a pilot that didn't go. pilot firing story too. I love it. About a pilot that didn't go. So I did the...
是的。现在，在我不可思议的研究中，你真的参与过《新鲜王子妙事多》吗？有趣的是，我确实参与了。我出演了《新鲜王子妙事多》的第一集，我还有一个关于一个没拍成的试播集的有趣被开除的故事。试播集被开除的故事。我喜欢这个。关于一个没拍成的试播集。所以我做了……
I think it was the second or third episode of the Fresh Prince, where Will was still super green. He's like mouthing everyone's words, you know, along with his... So he'd say his line and he's staring at you and you say your line and he... Yeah, he's mouthing it. That's such a thing. We've all worked with people who do that. It's such an actor thing, right? Yeah, he's mouthing it. That's such a thing. We've all worked with people who do that. It's such an actor thing, right? Yeah. You're like, are you mouthing my dialogue to me as I'm saying it?
我想那是《新鲜王子妙事多》的第二或第三集，威尔当时还非常稚嫩。他就像在跟着每个人的台词对口型，你知道，跟着他的……所以他说他的台词时盯着你，你说你的台词时他……是的，他在对口型。这真是个典型现象。我们都和这样的人共事过。这真是个演员的毛病，对吧？是的，他在对口型。这真是个典型现象。我们都和这样的人共事过。这真是个演员的毛病，对吧？是的。你会想，我说话的时候你在跟着我对口型吗？
Yeah. So he was so studious. He knew everybody's lines and then he would like mouth everybody's lines. But so we did that one and by the third or fourth show, the creators, Susan and Andy Borowitz, who were the head writers on the show, they said, we want to do a show around you. Uh-oh. Not necessarily based on the character that you're playing on this,
是的。所以他非常用功。他知道每个人的台词，然后他就会跟着对每个人的台词。但我们拍了那一集，到了第三或第四集，创作者苏珊和安迪·波罗维茨，也就是节目的首席编剧，他们说，我们想围绕你做一个节目。噢哦。不一定基于你在这个节目里扮演的角色，
but we just want to do a show around you. And I was like, okay. That's cool. So they wrote this show. How old were you? When I did Fresh Prince. Yeah. Early 20s? Is that really germaine to the story?
但我们只是想围绕你做一个节目。我就说，好的。那很酷。所以他们写了这个节目。你当时多大？拍《新鲜王子妙事多》的时候。是的。20出头？这和故事有关系吗？
I mean he's just gonna come in with the out hold dream. I was six, okay? I was fucking six. No, he's just jealous. He's just jealous because he's like, when are you getting offers for your own show? And he's like, I worked my whole life. Michael Landon didn't create a show for me.
我是说他只是想带着那个梦想进来。我当时六岁，好吗？我他妈才六岁。不，他只是嫉妒。他只是嫉妒，因为他会想，你什么时候能收到属于你自己的节目邀约？他会想，我努力工作了一辈子。迈克尔·兰登可没为我创作过节目。
Sorry JB, I know that shit. Michael Landon. So the third day they come down, they're like, we're gonna do the show. I said, okay, great, so they wrote this pilot. We shot the pilot, it's called In the House. I wrote the theme song to the thing. No way, cool.
抱歉JB，我知道那件事。迈克尔·兰登。所以第三天他们过来，他们说，我们要拍这个节目。我说，好的，太棒了，所以他们写了这个试播集。我们拍了试播集，叫《In the House》。我写了主题曲。不会吧，太酷了。
Everything was great. Heavy saxophone. Super, super heavy saxophone. It was on the schedule. And I'm pretty like, I don't believe it until I see it. And I just kind of wasn't believing that it was real. And also it just was a huge thing. It was the biggest thing that had happened
一切都很棒。沉重的萨克斯。超级、超级沉重的萨克斯。它在排期表上。我这个人比较……除非亲眼看到，否则我不相信。我当时有点不相信这是真的。而且这确实是一件大事。这是我当时职业生涯中发生过的最大的事。
in my career at that point. I was like, I don't, something's telling me this isn't real. But it was on the schedule, it was going. So like the day before I got this faithful call, I gave my brother my car, I was like, hey, it's on, take the car, I'm about to have this huge windfall. Yeah.
我当时想，我不，有什么东西告诉我这不是真的。但它在排期表上，正在进行。所以就在我接到那个致命电话的前一天，我把车给了我兄弟，我说，嘿，成了，把车拿去吧，我马上就要有一笔巨大的横财了。是的。
I'm ready, and the next day I got a call and they said it's off the schedule. It was, how old I was was Brendan Tartikoff was still running NBC at that time. Okay, we're late 80s. I don't know if people are listening now, no. Yeah, Brandon, yeah. But when he stepped down and Warren Littlefield came in, he killed all the shows that were under Brandon.
我准备好了，第二天我接到电话，他们说它被从排期表上撤下了。当时，我多大年纪……布兰登·塔蒂科夫当时还在管理NBC。好吧，那是80年代末。我不知道现在听众知不知道，不。是的，布兰登，是的。但当他下台，沃伦·利特菲尔德接手时，他砍掉了所有布兰登手下的节目。
That was one of them. That was one of the cast. You know, Sean, Sean, you told me a story, and correct me if I'm wrong, about where you shot the pilot because they had mignonette sauce instead of cocktail sauce for your oysters. Is that true? And you guys were about to leave Van Nuys and you were so mad. You were shocked.
那是其中之一。那是演员阵容之一。你知道，肖恩，肖恩，你给我讲过一个故事，如果我错了请纠正我，关于你们在哪里拍的试播集，因为你们的牡蛎配的是红葱头酱而不是鸡尾酒酱。是真的吗？你们当时正要离开范奈斯，你非常生气。你很震惊。
Because you were like, I hate mignonette sauce. I like cocktail sauce. And you shot the pilot out the month of June. But I spared the co-pilot. As a lesson so he could live to tell the story to other pilots about to get the sauces right. Now, all right. So now Don, could you imagine if that show had taken off, became a big success, you would have been a big sitcom star,
因为你说，我讨厌红葱头酱。我喜欢鸡尾酒酱。你们在六月份拍的试播集。但我饶了副驾驶。作为一个教训，这样他就能活着把这个故事讲给其他即将拿到酱料的试播集剧组听。好了，好了。那么唐，你能想象如果那个节目成功了，成为了一部大热的情景喜剧，你就会成为一位大情景喜剧明星，
I wonder where your career would have gone and what would have happened. I was thinking the same thing. Like, but like, even, so going back before that, was there another significant fork in the road, either where you grew up, like a fateful move to a certain city, or what your parents were doing or saying or sibling, where you could have easily seen, oh, if I'd just simply gone right instead of left,
我好奇你的职业生涯会走向何方，会发生什么。我也在想同样的事情。就像，回到那之前，还有没有其他重要的十字路口，无论是在你成长的地方，比如搬到一个特定的城市，或者你父母在做什么或说什么，或者兄弟姐妹，你可以很容易地看到，哦，如果我只是向右走而不是向左走，
I would be a veterinarian today. Or I would be an architect today. Or was there a fork that would clearly? That's such a good question. Thank you. I mean, it's crazy that my fallback was music. Like if this acting thing doesn't work out, I'll be a jazz musician, that'll get me there.
我今天会是一名兽医。或者我今天会是一名建筑师。或者有没有一个明显的岔路口？这是个好问题。谢谢。我是说，疯狂的是我的后路是音乐。就像如果演戏这条路走不通，我就去当爵士乐手，那能让我实现目标。
It's like, so, I mean, that's where I was trending. That's what I wanted to do. And quite honestly, there's still no greater pleasure that I have in any sort of performance capacity than being with musicians and creating music. Really, really. That's to me the highest. I love that. It is, it really is. I think because of, as you were talking about improvisation, that you're creating things spontaneously. I don't know what it's doing biochemically to you, but I'm sure if you have electrodes on and, you know, they were testing you, you're getting dopamine hits that are just through the roof
所以，我是说，那就是我当时的趋势。那就是我想做的。老实说，在任何表演能力方面，我仍然没有比和音乐家在一起创作音乐更大的乐趣了。真的，真的。对我来说那是最高境界。我喜欢这个。确实，真的是这样。我想是因为，正如你所说的即兴创作，你在自发地创造事物。我不知道它在生化层面上对你有什么影响，但我敢肯定，如果你戴上电极，你知道，他们测试你，你会得到多巴胺的冲击，简直是爆表，
because it's just so alive. Yeah. And it necessitates this connection with these fellow, pardon the term, artists that you're kind of communicating without speaking and there's a handoff and a yes and thing. You get that also in acting, but yeah. You do and there's also that thing you do when you perform live, when you also get that feedback from an audience when you're on stage, and you get that thing, and it starts to inform you a little bit. They become part of your creative process
因为它太鲜活了。是的。而且它需要与这些同伴——请原谅这个词——艺术家建立这种联系，你们在不说话的情况下进行交流，有一种交接和“是的，而且”的互动。你在演戏中也能得到这一点，但是的。你确实能得到，而且当你现场表演时，当你从观众那里得到反馈时，你也会得到那种东西，它开始给你一点启发。他们成为了你创作过程的一部分，
because you get juice from that, I think. Yeah, yeah, I agree. Absolutely, you do. And it transcends language, and it transcends English, Spanish it transcends the English, the Spanish. We can all speak this language. And so there's a big unifying thing that it does that's just like beyond.
因为我认为你能从中获得动力。是的，是的，我同意。绝对是这样。它超越了语言，超越了英语、西班牙语，它超越了英语、西班牙语。我们都能说这种语言。所以它有一种巨大的统一作用，简直是超越了这一切。
I had the same thing, Don. I always had music to fall back on, should the acting thing, and I still have the music to fall back on if the acting thing doesn't work out. But I always thought my fallback was gonna be, oh, I'll just be a pop star. Well, you can take your ass off,
我有同样的经历，唐。我总是有音乐作为后路，以防演戏这条路……而且如果演戏这条路走不通，我仍然有音乐作为后路。但我一直以为我的后路会是，哦，我会成为一名流行歌星。好吧，你可以脱掉你的屁股，
so you had a shot. Well, no, but when I was younger. Can we just play a little bit of it right now? We do this every once in a while, Don. Sean? Yeah, no. Now, Don, do you? Don, do you?
所以你曾经有机会。好吧，不，但当我年轻的时候。我们现在能放一点点吗？我们偶尔会这样做，唐。肖恩？是的，不。现在，唐，你？唐，你？
Bennett's gonna find it for us, and he's gonna play before Don leaves. Bennett or Rob are gonna play. Drop that needle, Bennett. Hey, Don, do you have a place where you go like Woody Allen famously took his clarinet out? I don't know once a week or whatever and that that's not a Right in there will but You're my favorite guy on the podcast
贝内特会帮我们找到它，他会在唐离开之前播放。贝内特或罗伯会播放。放下唱针，贝内特。嘿，唐，你有没有一个地方，像伍迪·艾伦那样，每周拿出一周一次还是什么的单簧管出来吹？我不知道，那不是一个……就在那里，威尔，但你是播客里我最喜欢的人。
Just a place where you go whip out your sax and go play it? I just said, Will got that one. You don't have to jump on top of Will's thing. Hey, hear what I did? Jump on top of Will's thing. Your turn, Sean. Get in there. I'll take it off.
只是一个你可以拿出来吹萨克斯的地方？我刚说了，威尔抓住了那个。你不必跳到威尔的话题上。嘿，听到我做了什么吗？跳到威尔的话题上。轮到你了，肖恩。进去吧。我会把它拿掉。
Like, but like, do you have, do you have, take it off? There it is. Um, do you have a band that you play with or a jazz club that you go to every once in a while? No, and I've been like bouncing around on... So I played the sax and then I didn't do that. You know, when I went to Cal Arts, it was kind of like a conservatory, the amount of time that you had to spend on all... There was no time really to do anything but theater and voice and movement and dance
就像，但是，你有，你有，拿掉它？就在那儿。嗯，你有一个和你一起演奏的乐队，或者一个你偶尔去的爵士俱乐部吗？没有，我一直在……所以我吹萨克斯，然后我就没再做了。你知道，当我上加州艺术学院时，它有点像音乐学院，你必须花在所有……上的时间，真的没有时间做除了戏剧、声音、动作和舞蹈之外的任何事情，
and all that stuff. So I just kind of dropped it. And then I was in New York doing a play and I walked by a pawn shop and I saw this beautiful tenor sax and I was like, I'm gonna pick it back up again. I'm gonna see if I have any facility because you lose your embouchure,
以及所有那些东西。所以我有点放弃了。然后我在纽约演一部戏，我路过一家当铺，我看到了这把漂亮的次中音萨克斯，我就想，我要把它重新捡起来。我要看看我还有没有能力，因为你会失去你的口型，
you lose that musculature to be able to play it It's hard to get it back. So I started playing it again. It sounded terrible I was like no just hang out just like stay with it. So I started doing that and then I Took a gig actually the rat pack movie and playing Sammy Davis jr. Who the Rat Pack movie and playing Sammy Davis Jr. who played drums and played trumpet and gun twirled and could play piano. Yeah. So I went back to school again,
你会失去那种演奏所需的肌肉力量，很难找回来。所以我开始重新练习。听起来糟透了。我就想，不，坚持住，就像坚持下去。所以我开始那样做，然后我接了一个演出，实际上是《十一罗汉》电影，扮演萨米·戴维斯二世，他会打鼓、吹小号、转枪，还能弹钢琴。是的。所以我又回到了学校，
having lessons from all of these teachers to learn how to do all these different things. That's when I started trying to pick up the trumpet, which became something that I didn't know I was going gonna need later when I did the Miles Davis thing. So I've been playing bass more than anything lately, and piano more than anything lately. I haven't gone back to the sax. I did bring, I bought a really beautiful brand new sax and let this dude play,
从所有这些老师那里上课，学习如何做所有这些不同的事情。那时我开始尝试拿起小号，这成了我后来做迈尔斯·戴维斯那个项目时没想过会需要的东西。所以我最近弹贝斯比什么都多，弹钢琴也比什么都多。我还没回到萨克斯上。我确实带了，我买了一把非常漂亮全新的萨克斯，让这家伙吹，
and he just recorded an album with it. And it's like, so it's always in the periphery somewhere, but I haven't, you know, I think the most amazing experience I had in musical experience in the last couple of years was, Rob Glasper was at his, he was recording something. He said, hey, come by, come listen. And I said, yeah, keep a track open
他刚用它录了一张专辑。所以它总是在外围的某个地方，但我还没有，你知道，我认为我在过去几年里最棒的音乐体验是，罗伯·格拉斯珀在他那里，他正在录制一些东西。他说，嘿，过来，过来听听。我说，好的，保持一个轨道打开，
because I'm going to bring the bass and I'm just going to like, you know, kill you guys with some shit. So just keep the track open. I was completely joking. And so I came over and I listened to him for a while and he goes, okay, here's the bass, let's go. I said, no, no, no, I was joking.
因为我要带上贝斯，我要，你知道，用一些东西震慑你们。所以保持轨道打开。我完全是在开玩笑。所以我过去听了他一会儿，他说，好的，这是贝斯，开始吧。我说，不，不，不，我是在开玩笑。
I don't wanna play. He's like, oh no, you're gonna play. And it became sort of like, you know, trial by fire. And I don't play like that, but when you play with great musicians, you know that they lift you up. Yeah. It's just like acting.
我不想弹。他说，哦不，你会弹的。这变得有点像，你知道，火的试炼。我不那样弹，但当你和伟大的音乐家一起演奏时，你知道他们会提升你。是的。就像演戏一样。
I wish I could find that. Yeah. People lift me up. It's fucking unbelievable. I'm just dragging these two. You're just stuck with these guys. Don, you seem to be like so great at surrounding your life with the things that mean,
我希望我能找到那个。是的。人们提升我。这他妈太不可思议了。我只是拖着这两个人。你只是被这些人困住了。唐，你似乎非常擅长让你的生活围绕着那些有意义的事情，
you know, have great value to, music, acting, family. You always seem to be in a great mood to like, is golf, yeah. How do you do that? How do you, for people who don't know how to do that, where they're like, I'm in this rut, like to us, we've all found the thing that we love to do or things we love to do.
你知道，有巨大价值的，音乐，演戏，家庭。你似乎总是心情很好，比如，高尔夫，是的。你是怎么做到的？你是怎么，对于那些不知道怎么做的人，他们会说，我陷入了这种困境，就像我们，我们都找到了我们热爱做的事情或我们热爱做的事情。
How did you learn how to gravitate towards the good versus the bad? You know, the things that are good for you, the things that fill your soul. Rather than. This is a question, this is an interviewer, Will. This is somebody who knows how to shape a question, okay? Sorry, go ahead, Don.
你是怎么学会向好的方向而不是坏的方向靠拢的？你知道，那些对你有益的事情，那些充实你灵魂的事情。而不是。这是一个问题，这是一个采访者，威尔。这是一个知道如何塑造问题的人，好吗？抱歉，继续，唐。
I love the commentary. I'm just here for the pot shots from the sideline, man. You know that. Will's killing, and you're killing the pot shots from the sideline, by the You know that. Will's killing, and you're killing the potshots from the sideline by the way. Thank you, I appreciate it, man. Yeah. Don't encourage him. I honestly have to attribute a lot of it,
我喜欢这种评论。我只是为了场边的冷枪而来的，伙计。你知道的。威尔表现得很好，而你也在场边放冷枪，顺便说一句。你知道的。威尔表现得很好，而你也在场边放冷枪，顺便说一句。谢谢，我很感激，伙计。是的。别鼓励他。我老实说必须把很多归功于，
I have to attribute a lot of it to my upbringing. I was very fortunate to have, and people get to it however they get to it. I was very fortunate to have really solid parents, really sort of corny, traditional picket fence, three, you know, the 3.5 kids and a dog and the whole thing. I really was able to grow up like that with parents that never dissuaded me from going after
我必须把很多归功于我的成长经历。我非常幸运，人们无论如何都会达到那个目标。我非常幸运有非常稳固的父母，非常那种老套的、传统的篱笆墙，你知道，3.5个孩子和一条狗，整套东西。我真的能够那样成长，父母从未劝阻我追求
what I wanted to go after. That's great. I think it was, you know, really fortunate that my mom was sort of a frustrated performer, a frustrated singer, so when I wanted to be an actor, she was like, yes! So after that. Do you have an older sibling that knocked the crap out of you when you got too big? Yeah, well, she's a girl, so I took advantage of the different muscles.
我想要追求的东西。那太棒了。我想，你知道，真的很幸运，我妈妈是一个有点受挫的表演者，一个受挫的歌手，所以当我想成为一名演员时，她就像，太好了！所以在那之后。你有一个哥哥或姐姐在你变得太自大时把你打得落花流水吗？是的，好吧，她是女孩，所以我利用了不同的肌肉。
I was stronger than her. And then we moved into weapons, and that's when it was like, oh, she's leveled the playing field, so we gotta chill out, and that's when we stopped fighting. But just really close-knit family, and it's something I think I just wanted to replicate in my life, and I'm really lucky that I have friends from when I was in elementary school still,
我比她强壮。然后我们开始使用武器，那时我就想，哦，她拉平了竞争环境，所以我们得冷静下来，那时我们就停止打架了。但只是非常亲密的家庭，我认为我只是想在我的生活中复制它，我很幸运，我有从小学开始就一直在一起的朋友，
and from college, and the people that I'm close to are still in my life. And I think we all know people who have gotten to a certain place and have looked around and they don't know anybody that's, no one that around them has been around them for five years. And you go, that person's probably gonna have some problems. So you need people who will laugh at you
还有大学的朋友，我亲近的人仍然在我的生活中。我想我们都知道一些人，他们到了某个地方，环顾四周，他们不认识任何……周围没有人是认识了五年以上的。你会想，那个人可能会有一些问题。所以你需要那些会嘲笑你的人，
and say, you're not important, chill out. I don't keep those people around because people can't breathe the air up here the way I can. Yeah, you're one of those people we were talking about, Will. The air is so thin up here. It's so rarefied that I can bear it. I'm handing out masks to these two
并说，你并不重要，冷静点。我不让那些人留在身边，因为人们无法像我一样呼吸这里的空气。是的，你是我们刚才谈到的那些人之一，威尔。这里的空气太稀薄了。太稀薄了，我能忍受。我正在给这两个人发口罩，
because I'm like, guys, we're going on a ride. We're going somewhere. We're going down, or we're going down. No, it's so important. I love that it is a measure of somebody by the way How many old friends they have from back in the day and I think I'm with you on that I think it's really great. I've got a lot of my old yeah buddies too now now Don I got a question here You've been a part of so many incredible projects. I want to know if
因为我在想，伙计们，我们要去兜风了。我们要去某个地方。我们要下去了，或者我们要下去了。不，这太重要了。我喜欢这种衡量某人的方式，顺便说一句，他们有多少从过去一直到现在的老朋友，我想我在这一点上和你是一样的。我认为这真的很棒。我也有一堆老伙计。现在，现在唐，我这里有个问题。你参与了这么多不可思议的项目。我想知道
you've been a part of so many incredible projects. I wanna know if any of them felt or smelled like turds right in the middle of it and you were shocked at the end of it that it turned out so well. Projects like Crash, Ocean's 11, 12 or 13, Traffic, Out of Sight, Boogie Nights, I mean, yeah, any of the Marvel stuff. Did any of them just go, oh, Jesus, what did I do here? I think I've had the opposite,
你参与了这么多不可思议的项目。我想知道其中有没有任何一个在过程中感觉或闻起来像屎一样，而你对它最终结果如此之好感到震惊。像《撞车》、《十一罗汉》、《十二罗汉》或《十三罗汉》、《毒品网络》、《战略高手》、《不羁夜》，我是说，是的，任何漫威的东西。有没有哪一个让你觉得，哦，天哪，我在这里做了什么？我想我正好相反，
where I'm like, this thing's gonna crush, and then it comes out and I'm like, ooh. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Not so much. Not so much, right. I mean, we don't know, right? You just go in with your best, you've made the best decision you could
我当时想，这东西会大火，然后它出来时我就想，噢。是的，是的，是的，是的。没那么多。没那么多，对吧。我是说，我们不知道，对吧？你只是带着你最好的状态进去，你做出了你能做的最好的决定，
and you go in and throw everything into it and then sometimes it works out and sometimes it doesn't. But I've never, you know, I've always had, I've always believed that the thing I've said yes to has value and it's gonna be good and the experiences and then it turns into being what it's going to be. I've been really fortunate to have really, really great experiences. I've had very few experiences where it's a toxic set and people are horrible.
然后你进去投入一切，有时它成功了，有时它没有。但我从来没有，你知道，我一直相信我答应的事情是有价值的，它会是好的，经历也是，然后它变成了它会成为的样子。我非常幸运，有过非常、非常棒的经历。我很少有那种剧组有毒、人们很糟糕的经历。
The things I've gravitated toward have gotten made and I've just been very, very fortunate. I've had a very blessed career. You've clearly got a nice connection going with Steven Soderbergh, yeah? Yeah. I heard the set of Chernobyl was toxic. Nice, Will. Hey, uh.
我倾向于的事情都拍成了，我只是非常、非常幸运。我的职业生涯非常受祝福。你显然和史蒂文·索德伯格有很好的联系，对吧？是的。我听说《切尔诺贝利》的剧组有毒。不错，威尔。嘿，呃。
That's a great show. But you and Soderbergh have a great rhythm going, yeah? You see working with him again in the future, probably? Yes, of course, right? Yeah, I mean mean we have stuff, we're trying to develop things as we speak. There's a couple things. I love, Out of Sight is such a great fucking movie, man.
那是个很棒的节目。但你和索德伯格有很好的节奏，对吧？你看到未来还会和他合作吗，大概？是的，当然，对吧？是的，我是说我们有东西，我们正在开发东西。有几件事。我喜欢，《战略高手》真是一部他妈的好电影，伙计。
Isn't it good? So underrated and overlooked. It's such a good movie. God damn it. Despite Clooney's looks, it's so good. No, I know, it's tough to get around. But Soderbergh's such a beast. Soderbergh's a good guy too, but I mean, writing and directing
它不好吗？被严重低估和忽视了。它真是一部好电影。该死的。尽管克鲁尼长得帅，但它太好了。不，我知道，很难绕过这一点。但索德伯格真是个野兽。索德伯格也是个好人，但我是说，写作和导演
and camera operating and editing, and I just, I would imagine that's gotta be an easy voice to follow considering he's kind of- Are you trying to dovetail into you? Cause that's what you're doing now? No, no, no, no, that's what I'd like to do. But can I take a minute to honestly actually- Here you go.
以及摄影和剪辑，我只是，我想那一定是一个很容易跟随的声音，考虑到他有点——你是在试图过渡到你自己吗？因为你现在正在做那个？不，不，不，不，那是我想要做的。但我能花一分钟老实说实际上——给你。
Here we go. Spike it. Spike it. He served it up. You might as well spike it. There you go. Guys, take a second. I do want to spike it.
开始了。扣杀它。扣杀它。他发球了。你最好扣杀它。给你。伙计们，等一下。我确实想扣杀它。
I'm a big Jason Bateman fan. I'm just going to say I'm a big Jason Bateman fan. I'm really... I love everything that I'm seeing you do. And I saw you in a roundtable talking about, you know, understanding as an actor what you were going to be doing as an editor and knowing when you get into the editing room, what you're gonna be able to use and not use and how you're gonna craft your performance based on that.
我是杰森·贝特曼的超级粉丝。我只想说我是杰森·贝特曼的超级粉丝。我真的很……我喜欢我看到你做的一切。我看到你在一个圆桌会议上谈论，你知道，作为一名演员，理解你作为剪辑师要做什么，并且知道当你进入剪辑室时，你将能够使用什么，不能使用什么，以及你将如何基于此来打造你的表演。
And I was like, that's so fucking smart and such a cheat. But it's really fun. It's really fun. Cause he lives his personal life like an editor too. So he's always thinking about the results. He's trying to cut you off. Fuck off.
我就想，那太他妈聪明了，简直是作弊。但这真的很有趣。这真的很有趣。因为他在个人生活中也像个剪辑师一样生活。所以他总是考虑结果。他试图切断你。去你的。
Yeah, trimming you. Well, now what Don's doing here is he's dovetailing into his accomplishments as a director as well. That he has. I wanted to get in there. He has gone ahead and he's taken all the incredible set experience he's had and lent that to the directing experience, right?
是的，修剪你。好吧，现在唐在这里做的是，他也过渡到了他作为导演的成就。他确实有。我想进去。他已经继续前进，并利用了他所有的不可思议的片场经验，并将其借给了导演经验，对吧？
And it made everybody's life a lot easier, I would imagine. Do you do? Do you, it'll come on. Why not? Bullshit, you must love it. I don't anticipate ever doing it again. Why?
我想这会让每个人的生活都轻松得多。你做吗？你，它会来的。为什么不？胡说，你一定喜欢它。我不指望再做一次。为什么？
Come on, you've done it a handful of times at least. That was enough. Really? Why? Why? Is it the workload or the pressure or the time commitment or what? It's the pressure. Why? Is it the workload or the pressure or the time commitment or what? It's the pressure.
得了吧，你至少做过几次了。那已经够了。真的吗？为什么？为什么？是工作量还是压力还是时间投入还是什么？是压力。为什么？是工作量还是压力还是时间投入还是什么？是压力。
Honestly, it's the pressure. I think, you know, my agent one time said, you know, good actors are just like, can be and sometimes need to just be hard sons of bitches. They just have to be able to, not necessarily in how they deal with people, but you have to have the ability to have stuff kind of roll off and be thick-skinned and not have it be, you know, penetrate and keep moving. And I think I have more, I'm more like sort of bandied about by the things that happen and the things I wasn't able to get.
老实说，是压力。我想，你知道，我的经纪人有一次说，你知道，好的演员就像，可以是，有时需要只是坚强的混蛋。他们只是必须能够，不一定是在他们如何对待人方面，但你必须有能力让事情随风而去，脸皮厚一点，不要让它，你知道，渗透进去，然后继续前进。我想我有更多，我更像是被发生的事情和我无法得到的事情所摆布。
And I just, and it's something that I learned about myself going through that experience. I'm like, oh, I'm a lot more porous in that regard than I thought I was. Yeah, as an actor, you can ignore a lot of drama or problems or complications with the production and you just kind of sit in your trailer and then someone else will figure it out.
我只是，这是我在经历那个过程中对自己了解到的事情。我就想，哦，我在那方面比我想象的要脆弱得多。是的，作为一名演员，你可以忽略很多戏剧性事件或问题或制作上的复杂情况，你只是坐在你的拖车里，然后别人会解决它。
So as a director, you can't hide from anything. None of those things. Don, you bring up a really good point though It is true, you know actors as we know historically you take a lot of heat and people go like oh fucking actors Are you hear people right? Like even people you grew up with like what's your life like now? You're an actor you see the people have this sort of thing and and I always say and they're like, oh, yeah But you're just an actor and I'm thinking like yeah, I I am friends with I am an actor
所以作为一名导演，你无法躲避任何事情。那些事情都不行。唐，你提出了一个很好的观点，虽然这是真的，你知道演员，正如我们所知，历史上你承受了很多压力，人们会说，哦，他妈的演员。你听到人们了吗？甚至是你一起长大的人，比如你现在的生活是什么样的？你是个演员，你看到人们有这种东西，我总是说，他们就像，哦，是的，但你只是个演员，我想，是的，我，我是……的朋友，我是一名演员，
I'm friends with tons of actors, they're some of the most creative, amazing people, and on top of that, to what you were saying, they're also, it is a tough road, as you know, from when you're younger to start to do the things that you wanna do, and you do put up with a ton of disappointment, you get kicked in the nards on a daily basis.
我是很多演员的朋友，他们是一些最有创造力、最了不起的人，最重要的是，正如你所说的，这也是一条艰难的路，正如你从年轻时开始做你想做的事情所知道的那样，你确实忍受了大量的失望，你每天都被踢蛋蛋。
My own experience, I lived in New York for 10 years and was trying to get fucking work and just got kicked in the nards on a daily basis. You know, my own experience, I lived in New York for 10 years and was trying to get fucking work and just got kicked in the nards and then as I'd go down to wincing in pain from getting kicked in the nuts, I'd get kicked in the face. You know, like Jason's like you saying, like, the show's not, here's the bad, you're fired and then the next day the show's fucking gone and you're like, fuck I didn't need those two kicks. And by the way, and it's not once a year, it's like two, three times a week, four years. And that's if things are going well for you
我自己的经历，我在纽约住了10年，试图得到他妈的工作，每天都被踢蛋蛋。你知道，我自己的经历，我在纽约住了10年，试图得到他妈的工作，每天都被踢蛋蛋，然后当我因为被踢蛋蛋而痛苦地畏缩时，我会被踢脸。你知道，就像杰森说的，就像你说的，节目不是，这是坏消息，你被解雇了，然后第二天节目他妈的没了，你就想，操，我不需要那两脚。顺便说一句，这不是一年一次，而是每周两三次，持续四年。如果你做得好的话，那才是，
because those two or three rejections each week mean you got two or three auditions that week, which is really good. And I'm not saying to feel sorry for it, but it is, right Don, it's a tough, you do have to have a little bit of you know you show your metal a little bit well for me I really could I sound like an idiot Aaron you know complaining about anything about my acting career because again I was super super fortunate. I've never done anything, but this to support myself
因为那每周两三次的拒绝意味着你那周有两三次试镜，这真的很好。我不是说要为它感到难过，但它是，对吧唐，这很艰难，你确实必须有一点，你知道，你展示一点你的勇气，好吧，对我来说，我真的能……我听起来像个白痴，亚伦，你知道，抱怨关于我演艺生涯的任何事情，因为再一次，我超级、超级幸运。我从来没做过任何事，除了这个来养活自己。
I you know got my first job when I was still in college. In my junior, I got a gig. Oh, I did get fired from a job. That was actually the first job. I got an AT&T commercial where a kid was supposed to be on the phone and sort of trying to dodge the questions that his mom was asking because he was not doing so well.
我，你知道，还在大学时就得到了我的第一份工作。在大三时，我得到了一个演出。哦，我确实被一份工作解雇了。那实际上是第一份工作。我得到了一个AT&T的广告，一个孩子应该在电话上，试图躲避他妈妈问的问题，因为他做得不太好。
She goes, how are your grades? And he's like, my grades, I can't hear you. This connection is bad. She's like, no, I can hear you great. And it was AT&T. You can't fake the funk. You know, it was one of those things. So I was running on my, I was going out of the door
她说，你的成绩怎么样？他就像，我的成绩，我听不见你说话。这个连接很差。她说，不，我能听得很清楚。那是AT&T。你不能伪造这种感觉。你知道，那是那种事情之一。所以我正跑向我的，我正要出门
to do this audition and the phone rang in the hallway and I just kind of knew it was for me. And I picked it up, it was my agent, she goes, uh, Don, bad news, they're not gonna use you in the spot. I was like, what, why? She goes, they don't want to portray a black kid as failing out of college. I was like, so they're gonna give a white kid my job?
去参加这个试镜，走廊里的电话响了，我只是有点知道那是给我的。我接了，是我的经纪人，她说，呃，唐，坏消息，他们不会在广告里用你了。我就想，什么，为什么？她说，他们不想把一个黑人孩子描绘成大学挂科。我就想，所以他们要给一个白人孩子我的工作？
Yeah. So. Wow, yeah, the irony of that. Yeah. That is crazy. That's what's gonna happen. So that, I actually did that. Yeah. That is crazy. That's what's going to happen. So that I actually did get fired from a job I got.
是的。所以。哇，是的，那真是讽刺。是的。那太疯狂了。这就是会发生的事情。所以那个，我确实做了那个。是的。那太疯狂了。这就是会发生的事情。所以那个我确实被一份我得到的工作解雇了。
That was the first one. But yeah, but for me, the acting thing has been, I've been, like I said, I've been very blessed, very fortunate. But the directing part of it, yeah, it's really just, it's been these particular experiences I've had. Not when I've directed my show. That's a little bit more of a comfort zone, a little bit more support I've had, and a little bit more resources and people to rely on. But we made Miles Ahead for $8.5 million
那是第一个。但是的，但对我来说，演戏这件事，我一直，就像我说的，我一直很受祝福，非常幸运。但导演那部分，是的，它真的只是，就是我经历过的这些特定的经历。不是当我导演我的节目时。那是一个更舒适的区域，我得到的支持更多，我有更多的资源和可以依靠的人。但我们以850万美元拍摄了《迈尔斯·戴维斯传》，
in a town that had only done one other movie before that where we would show up, and there was like no redundancy in the departments. We'd have two cameras and only one cameraman. I'd be like, where's Phil? It's like, oh, he took a commercial in Dayton. You know? You know, coming in one day,
在一个之前只拍过一部电影的小镇，我们出现时，部门里几乎没有冗余。我们会有两台摄像机，但只有一个摄影师。我会想，菲尔在哪？就像，哦，他在代顿接了一个广告。你知道吗？你知道，有一天进来，
and I was like, where's the, we had her in the scene. She's like, yeah, she didn't want to come today. I'm like, but she's in the scene. They're like, yeah, she doesn't want to come. So I'm like, put this woman in the dress, turn her back to the camera. Like every like, yeah, she doesn't want to come. So I'm like, put this woman in the dress, turn her back to the camera. Like every day it was something like that. Always solving problems.
我就想，那个……我们在场景里有她。她说，是的，她今天不想来。我就想，但她在场景里。他们就像，是的，她不想来。所以我就像，给这个女人穿上裙子，背对着摄像机。就像每一个，是的，她不想来。所以我就像，给这个女人穿上裙子，背对着摄像机。就像每天都有那样的事情。总是解决问题。
But the problems that didn't make sense, like the fire alarm going off and then the fire, then the actual fireman coming and coming in while we're shooting the scene. And so, okay, I guess we'll shoot this MOS and just mime all these things, we'll do it in post. You know, just every day if it's something like that. My wife came out to see me and she said,
但那些说不通的问题，比如火警响了，然后消防员，然后真正的消防员进来，在我们拍戏的时候进来。所以，好吧，我想我们拍这个MOS（无声拍摄），然后模仿所有这些事情，我们在后期做。你知道，每天如果都有那样的事情。我妻子出来看我，她说，
you can't do this anymore, you know, I lost weight. It was just, it was bad. So I have a lot of scar tissue. So maybe if I get, you know, some sort of procedure where I can scrape that off, I'll try it again. For the emotional scars. I have a question just about your acting style and approach because when I first saw Ocean's Eleven,
你不能再这样做了，你知道，我瘦了。这真的很糟糕。所以我有很多疤痕组织。所以也许如果我得到，你知道，某种我可以刮掉它的手术，我会再试一次。为了情感创伤。我有一个关于你的表演风格和方法的问题，因为当我第一次看到《十一罗汉》时，
which you were brilliant in, I'm not making this up. Like halfway through the movie because of your accent, I was like, oh, wait, is that Don Cheadle? Like you didn't do anything to your appearance. You just changed your kind of way. I don't know how to describe it. And it's amazing what an act, just an accent can do. How did you find the trust to do that?
你在里面表现得很出色，我不是在编造。就像电影演到一半时，因为你的口音，我就想，哦，等等，那是唐·钱德尔吗？你没在你的外表上做任何改变。你只是改变了你的那种方式。我不知道怎么形容。而且一个演员，仅仅一个口音就能做到这一点，真是太神奇了。你是怎么找到信任去做那个的？
Why that character like that? And how do you do that? Like in any character, your approach? It was written like that and I was going to change it. And my manager at that point said, there aren't black British people? I was like, oh, I mean, yeah. So why don't you just do it as how it's written? And I was like, yeah, fuck. Oh, so it was written.
为什么是那样的角色？你是怎么做到的？就像在任何角色中，你的方法？它是那样写的，我打算改变它。我当时的经理说，没有黑人英国人吗？我就想，哦，我是说，是的。那你为什么不照着写的做呢？我就想，是的，操。哦，所以它是写的。
I'll try it. And so while I'm in my trailer with, you know, a vocal coach, a speech coach going over like diphthongs and shvahs and stuff, they're out playing basketball. I'm like sitting in my chair watching them play poker and have fun and I'm like, no, this works. No, uh, no, uh, no, uh. Sean, stand up real quick. Sean's wearing a diphthong. Stand up real quick.
我会试试。所以当我在我的拖车里，和，你知道，声乐教练，语言教练一起过双元音和中央元音之类的东西时，他们在外面打篮球。我坐在我的椅子上看着他们打扑克，玩得很开心，我就想，不，这行得通。不，呃，不，呃，不，呃。肖恩，快站起来。肖恩戴着一个双元音。快站起来。
Oh, that's nice. That's a nice diphthong. But I was famously murdered. People hate, people are split right in the middle on that. But I was famously murdered. People are split right in the middle on that. The people that hate that hate it. When I was in London, I almost had to get security because people wanted to kill me based on how bad they thought that actually was. Oh, the accident in Ocean? Why?
哦，那很好。那是一个很好的双元音。但我被著名地谋杀了。人们讨厌，人们在这一点上意见分歧。但我被著名地谋杀了。人们在这一点上意见分歧。讨厌那个的人讨厌它。当我在伦敦时，我差点需要保安，因为人们想杀了我，基于他们认为那个口音有多糟糕。哦，海洋里的那个口音？为什么？
They hated it and me. People literally drove, they would see me and come across four lanes of traffic to pull up next to me to scream at me about how bad the accent was. I was like, why you guys are so serious about this? I totally bought it. I totally bought it. Is it safe to say you'll never do another British accent again?
他们讨厌它，也讨厌我。人们真的开车，他们会看到我，穿过四条车道停在我旁边，对我尖叫那个口音有多糟糕。我就想，为什么你们对这个这么认真？我完全相信了。我完全相信了。可以肯定地说你再也不会做英国口音了吗？
Ding ding ding ding ding. Yeah, doing an accent, that would be very, very tough for me, because you're acting twice, right? You gotta do performance and you gotta do the acting. And some somehow just fit. Would you make them pay twice, Jay? I know Jay very well. I would like to.
叮叮叮叮叮。是的，做口音，那对我来说会非常、非常困难，因为你在演两次，对吧？你必须表演，你还必须演戏。而且不知怎么就合适了。你会让他们付两次钱吗，杰伊？我非常了解杰伊。我想。
Would you make them pay twice? I would like to, I would like to. What are you gonna say, Dan? No, I'm just gonna say, and some of them, you know, fit better than others that I've attempted to take on. You know, but they're all, like you said, it's all tricky, like you said, it's all tricky. You're kind of acting through a mask
你会让他们付两次钱吗？我想，我想。你要说什么，丹？不，我只是要说，而且其中一些，你知道，比我尝试过的其他一些更合适。你知道，但它们都是，就像你说的，都很棘手，就像你说的，都很棘手。你有点像戴着面具在演戏，
and you're trying to make that mask be as real and as facile as you can. It's tricky. Right, right, right. Now, all of these incredibly high profile films, which one do you think gave you the most useful bounce? Was it Devil in the blue dress? Yeah? gave you the most useful bounce. Was it Devil in the Blue Dress? Yeah?
你试图让那个面具尽可能真实和灵活。这很棘手。对，对，对。现在，所有这些高知名度的电影，你认为哪一部给了你最有用的反弹？是《蓝衣魔鬼》吗？是的？给了你最有用的反弹。是《蓝衣魔鬼》吗？是的？
I would guess. Devil in the Blue Dress was probably, I was on Picket Fences for a couple years before that. Oh wow. You know, I was 12th on the call sheet and you guys know what that is. I'm sitting in the trailer all day and they're like, we're coming to you next,
我猜。在那之前，我大概在《小镇疑云》里演了几年。哦，哇。你知道，我在演员表上排第12位，你们知道那是什么意思。我整天坐在拖车里，他们就像，下一个就轮到你了，
we're coming to you next. And they're like, oh no, we're not gonna use you today and you've been in the trailer for 12 hours. So I started writing, that's when I started writing and just as survival, just to not go crazy. But then along comes this film with Denzel Washington and it was, did you leave that project with any pearls of wisdom from Mr. Washington?
我们马上就来找你。然后他们说，哦不，我们今天不用你了，而你已经在拖车里待了12个小时。所以我开始写作，那是我开始写作的时候，纯粹是为了生存，为了不让自己发疯。但后来有了这部丹泽尔·华盛顿的电影，你离开那个项目时，从华盛顿先生那里学到了什么真知灼见吗？
I mean, it was an incredible experience. It was directed by Carl Franklin, who I did his AFI thesis project, his graduation project, so I had known him from before. So that was really old home and felt great. And Denzel and I, from the audition on, which is online actually, our audition is online. Oh no way.
我的意思是，那是一次不可思议的经历。导演是卡尔·富兰克林，我曾参与过他的AFI毕业设计项目，所以我之前就认识他。所以那感觉就像回到了老家，感觉棒极了。我和丹泽尔，从试镜开始——其实那段试镜在网上能看到，我们的试镜在网上。哦，不会吧。
Yeah. And so is that pilot that I mentioned, by the way. Oh wow. People find shit and upload everything. But we just had a great time. And of course I was just in awe of him and, you know, worked as hard as I've ever worked on anything to make sure I was in the pocket when I was with him. I didn't come out, I was super Methodie, I was not great character, I was mouse all the time.
是的。顺便说一下，我提到的那个试播集也在网上。哦，哇。人们总能找到这些东西并上传一切。但我们相处得非常愉快。当然，我对他非常敬畏，你知道，我尽了我所能去努力工作，确保在和他搭戏时我能进入状态。我没有出戏，我非常讲究方法派，我不是在演角色，我一直就是那只老鼠。
I just stayed in it and yeah, I had a great experience. I loved that movie and I loved that experience. If you had, say you had a scene with a, because you're Denzel now to a young actor if you were to do a film with it, what would you say to a young actor today that you wish you'd known back when you were just starting out?
我一直沉浸在其中，是的，我有一段很棒的经历。我喜欢那部电影，也喜欢那段经历。如果你，比如说你现在对年轻演员来说就是丹泽尔了，如果你要和他们拍电影，你会对今天的年轻演员说些什么，是你希望自己在刚起步时就知道的？
You know, anything? Stay out of my fucking life. Right, exactly. Would you upstage me or shadow me? Don't you dare attempt to overshadow me. But we do have a tendency to overcomplicate things, right? And things get more simplistic as we get older. I wonder, aside from just that generality,
你知道，什么都行？离我的生活远点。对，没错。你是想抢我的戏还是想压过我？你敢试图抢我的风头。但我们确实倾向于把事情复杂化，对吧？随着年龄增长，事情会变得更简单。我好奇，除了那个普遍的道理，
is there anything specific, I'm trying to think myself, what I would tell somebody, you know? Probably step away from my BMW Which of your BMWs that's a great I just think that you know, like we I think people Underestimate, you know to what Will was saying earlier, is it what we really do. I think people think it's super, super easy and then they try it and they're like,
有没有什么具体的建议？我自己也在想，我会告诉别人什么呢？大概是离我的宝马远点。哪辆宝马？那太棒了。我只是觉得，你知道，我们，我觉得人们低估了，你知道，就像威尔刚才说的，我们到底在做什么。我觉得人们认为这超级超级简单，然后他们尝试了，他们就会说，
oh, you're actually trying to be very naturalistic inside a completely unnatural environment where somebody standing in your eyeline chewing gum and, you know, making noise off, somebody's, you know,ie-talkies going off and you've got to act like this is the first time you've ever done or said any of these things and so I think that you only do that well if you're really prepared and you've really done your homework and you're not here just because you think it's going to be cool to cut line at a restaurant you know it's like, this is really, we're not rocket scientists and we're not jumping out airplanes or whatever,
哦，你实际上是在一个完全不自然的环境中努力表现得非常自然，有人站在你的视线里嚼口香糖，你知道，在旁边制造噪音，有人在用对讲机，而你必须表现得好像这是你第一次做或说这些事情一样。所以我认为只有当你真正准备好，真正做了功课，而不是因为觉得在餐馆插队很酷才来这里时，你才能做好。你知道，这就像，我们不是火箭科学家，我们也不是从飞机上跳下来什么的，
the hardest shit there is to do or ditch digging, but there is a craft. But we can play them. That's what we play the shit out of. And we learn about them, that's another thing. Good actors are students, so we're always in the lab, we're always trying to, if I play a doctor, I'm gonna read up on doctors, I'm gonna follow doctors,
这不是最难的事情，也不是挖沟，但这是一门手艺。我们可以扮演他们。这就是我们擅长的。我们了解他们，这是另一回事。优秀的演员都是学生，所以我们总是在实验室里，我们总是在尝试，如果我扮演一名医生，我会阅读关于医生的资料，我会跟随医生，
I'm gonna go to hospitals, I'm gonna try to sit next to them. If I'm playing a cop, I'm gonna do a ride along. I'm gonna, so I feel like that part of it often gets overlooked, that we're always in school. We're always trying to learn new things. So I think that's a great boon for us as artists, that we're always expanding ourselves. Now, Sean doesn't want you to get away without,
我会去医院，我会试着坐在他们旁边。如果我扮演警察，我会去随警出勤。所以我觉得那部分经常被忽视，我们总是在学习。我们总是在尝试学习新事物。所以我认为这对我们作为艺术家来说是一个巨大的福音，我们总是在扩展自己。现在，肖恩不想让你就这么溜走，
you know, searching your memory for a really, a tough theater story, you know? Like, forgetting your lines or trying to give, you know? A sandbag fell from above and oh! And I landed in the first row in the woman's lap and she said, you think you're drunk, wait till O'Toole comes out or something like that, right Sean? Is that what you want? Oh, you were at that performance.
你知道，搜寻你的记忆，讲一个真正艰难的剧场故事，你知道？比如，忘词了，或者试图给，你知道？一个沙袋从上面掉下来，哦！我掉进了第一排那个女人的怀里，她说，你以为你喝醉了，等奥图尔出来再说，类似这样的话，对吧肖恩？这就是你想要的？哦，你当时在那场演出里。
You were there. That's exactly right. But I said, wait till my tool comes out. Yes! Double guns. Double guns. Don Shallant! Don Shallant strikes again.
你在那儿。完全正确。但我说，等我的“工具”出来再说。是的！双枪。双枪。唐·沙兰特！唐·沙兰特再次出击。
Fucker. Yes! Double guns. Yes! Don Shalant! Don Shalant strikes again. Is that you, Sean? Oh, this is me singing, yeah. It's horrible. Here we go. It's so bad. Okay. That's enough.
混蛋。是的！双枪。是的！唐·沙兰特！唐·沙兰特再次出击。那是你吗，肖恩？哦，这是我在唱歌，是的。太可怕了。开始了。太糟糕了。好了。够了。
Is that Tabla? Is that some Tabla? Okay, that's good. We're good. You know what it is? It's like the Okay. That's enough. Is that Tabla? Is that some Tabla? Okay, that's good. You know what it is? It's like Jimmy Summerville from Bronski Beat was put in the back of a van and driven to
那是塔布拉鼓吗？那是塔布拉鼓吗？好了，那很好。我们很好。你知道那是什么吗？就像是……好了。够了。那是塔布拉鼓吗？那是塔布拉鼓吗？好了，那很好。你知道那是什么吗？就像是来自Bronski Beat的吉米·萨默维尔被塞进了一辆货车的后座，被带到了
Beirut and forced to make a fucking Middle Eastern dance record. Jimmy Summerville in Beirut. That was the name of the album. Oh Sean. Yeah. Did you ever see, by the way, did you ever see Ricky Gervais's music videos or anything? Oh yeah, those were his. Yes. That's a similar path.
贝鲁特，被迫制作一张该死的中东舞曲唱片。贝鲁特的吉米·萨默维尔。那是专辑的名字。哦，肖恩。是的。顺便问一下，你有没有看过瑞奇·热维斯的音乐录影带之类的？哦，是的，那是他的。是的。那是类似的路径。
But yeah, do you have any like tragic, horrible theater gone wrong? My tragic, the most tragic thing, other than a real injury that I suffered during a play, same play by the way, we were. Same play, by the way. We were doing Cymbeline at the Public that Joanne Akilaitis directed, who is an experimental director from Mabu Minds, if people want to go back and look at all that stuff. She's great.
但是，你有过那种悲剧性的、糟糕的剧场翻车经历吗？我最悲剧的，除了我在演出中受到的真实伤害——顺便说一下，是同一部戏——我们当时在……顺便说一下，是同一部戏。我们在公共剧院排演《辛白林》，由乔安·阿基莱蒂斯执导，她是来自Mabu Minds的实验导演，如果人们想回去看看那些作品的话。她很棒。
But we had an actor, Stefan Schnabel, who played the doctor in this play. And you know, it's kind of a stereotypical Shakespeare fifth act wrap up where one character knows everything that happened in the play. Like, you're his niece and she actually has the potion. And this king knew him as a son. Like they unwrapped the whole thing
但我们有一位演员，斯特凡·施纳贝尔，他在戏里扮演医生。你知道，这是一种典型的莎士比亚第五幕收尾，一个角色知道戏里发生的一切。比如，你是他的侄女，而她实际上有药水。国王把他当作儿子。就像他们把整件事都揭开了，
and we're all on stage going, oh, that's how I did that. So he had this last speech that he had to give. Stefan was, I think, 98 at the time. Uh-oh. Wow. So it comes time for him to wrap this up and he goes up.
我们都在舞台上说，哦，原来我是这么做的。所以他有最后一段台词要说。斯特凡当时我想有98岁了。呃哦。哇。所以轮到他来收尾了，他上台了。
That forgets his lines. Yeah, forgets his line, goes up, forgets his lines for those who want the theater vernacular. And he starts stammering and making up words and basically just sort of like, you know, standing in place and teetering. And no one, you can't give somebody in Shakespeare, you know, it's not, we're not doing something naturalistic.
然后忘词了。是的，忘词了，上台，忘词了，用剧场行话来说就是“上去了”。他开始结巴，编造词汇，基本上就是，你知道，站在原地摇晃。没有人，你不能在莎士比亚的戏里给别人，你知道，我们不是在做自然主义的东西。
You can't come up with some, you could try to come up with some iambic pentameter and like slip a line there to help him along the way. But it went on so long that first the audience sort of laughed and then realized, oh, it's not a bit and stopped laughing. And then the other half the audience laughed and then half the audience shushed that part of the audience sort of laughed and then realized, oh, it's not a bit and stopped laughing. And then the other half the audience laughed and then half the audience shushed that part of the audience that laughed.
你不能想出一些，你可以试着想出一些抑扬格五音步，然后塞进一句台词帮他一把。但这持续了太久，以至于起初观众有点笑，然后意识到，哦，这不是个段子，就不笑了。然后另一半观众笑了，然后一半观众嘘那些笑的观众。
And then the actors on stage kind of were starting to laugh, those two that would start to laugh. And everyone's like, shut the fuck up. And then everybody stops laughing. And he's still kind of, you know. He's still trying to pull it off. He doesn't think anyone's noticed. Trying to pull it off.
然后台上的演员开始有点想笑，那两个开始笑的人。每个人都说，闭嘴。然后大家都停止了笑。而他还在，你知道。他还在试图撑过去。他以为没人注意到。试图撑过去。
This went on for probably two minutes. You know how long two minutes is. Yeah. Oh. I mean, you guys have died for two minutes for sure, collectively on this show, for 100%. It feels like a long time. Yeah, it's a long time.
这持续了大概两分钟。你知道两分钟有多长吗。是的。哦。我的意思是，你们在这个节目里肯定集体死机过两分钟，100%。感觉时间很长。是的，时间很长。
She says it's not. Joan Cusack, who was the lead in it, who played Cymbaline, just finally just started saying his lines. She just couldn't take it anymore. Yeah, just took over. And he kind of revved up and got through it, and then got off stage and he said,
她说不是。琼·库萨克，她是主角，扮演辛白林，终于开始说他的台词了。她实在受不了了。是的，直接接管了。他振作了一下，完成了表演，然后下台说，
"'I wanna kill myself, I have to quit, I never wanna act again.'" And you're like, you're 98, there's no point. Oh, sorry. Yeah, you're gonna be dead soon, I guess, is what Joan said to try to like, you know, bolster his ego. Good Lord, yeah, that's the scariest thing I've ever heard.
“我想自杀，我必须辞职，我再也不想演戏了。”而你会说，你都98岁了，没必要这样。哦，抱歉。是的，你快要死了，我想这就是琼为了，你知道，增强他的自尊心而说的话。天哪，是的，这是我听过最可怕的事情。
Wow, fuck. Good Lord, yeah. That's the scariest thing I've ever heard. Wow, fuck. It was really sad. Going up in your dialogue like that on stage. It's the scariest thing in the world. Right? There's just nothing. Yeah, you don't need that crap at 98. There's nowhere to hide.
哇，该死。天哪，是的。这是我听过最可怕的事情。哇，该死。这真的很悲伤。在舞台上忘词成那样。这是世界上最可怕的事情。对吧？什么都没有了。是的，98岁了不需要那种烂事。无处可藏。
Yeah, there's nowhere to hide. Right. But now, Don, you're like one of the sweetest people ever. What pisses you off? Because I can't, the few times I've met you, even today, you're always just very in the middle, very cool, calm, collected. Is there some?
是的，无处可藏。对。但现在，唐，你是有史以来最可爱的人之一。什么会让你生气？因为我无法，我见过你几次，即使是今天，你总是非常平和，非常冷静、沉着。有没有什么？
What's that? I said I'm on that gummy program. Yeah. I bet he's not happy when he blades a bunker shot, right? You hit that ball right in the belly, coming out of the sand trap, it's just, you're never happy. That's what pisses you off.
什么？我说我正在参加那个软糖计划。是的。我敢打赌他在沙坑球打不好时肯定不高兴，对吧？你从沙坑里出来，球打在肚子上，这简直，你永远不会高兴。这就是让你生气的地方。
Yeah. Immediately, but then just, you're never happy. That's what pisses you off. Yeah. Immediately, but then I kind of let it go. I think stupidity without any desire to not be stupid pisses me off. I don't mind if you're stupid. People can be stupid. But when there are like, incurious and don't want to actually look under the stupidity
是的。立刻，但随后我就放下了。我认为没有不想变聪明的欲望的愚蠢会让我生气。我不介意你愚蠢。人们可以愚蠢。但当他们表现得，不好奇，不想真正去探究愚蠢的根源，
and see where that stupidity is coming from. That kind of pisses me. And, you know, as we can see, it's incredibly dangerous. And, you know, we're in a sweet spot of stupidity right now for a lot of people. And would that extend across all sort of areas, that sort of stupidity, like whether it's history or language or just geography, even basic geography of states and cities
看看那种愚蠢从何而来。那种事情会让我生气。而且，你知道，正如我们所见，这极其危险。而且，你知道，我们现在正处于许多人愚蠢的甜蜜点。这种愚蠢会延伸到所有领域吗，比如历史、语言，或者仅仅是地理，甚至是州和城市的基本地理知识，
Within the country that we live. Oh House where city was Been explained to them like five times No, I think wills just trying to use General I'm just trying to get a general sense of what's going on. Because Sean, remember earlier in the show, I had a problem with Kansas City. Well, ignorance isn't stupidity. Ignorance is anyone can be ignorant.
在我们居住的国家内。哦，房子，城市在哪里，已经被解释了五次了。不，我觉得威尔只是想用通用的。我只是想了解一下大概的情况。因为肖恩，记得节目早些时候，我对堪萨斯城有问题。好吧，无知不是愚蠢。无知是任何人都可以无知的。
That's true. Anybody can be ignorant. Thank you, Jason. So Don, honestly, you've been a dream. You're such a cool guy. We've never hung out. We threatened once. I was on a, I was, Joey Russo wanted me to get into a football fantasy league and I said no and Joe said, well just stay in the chat and talk shit even though you don't wanna play. And I did for about six months I think.
那是真的。任何人都可以无知。谢谢你，杰森。所以唐，老实说，你一直是个梦想。你真是个酷家伙。我们从来没一起玩过。我们威胁过一次。我当时在，我当时，乔伊·鲁索想让我加入一个橄榄球梦幻联盟，我说不，乔说，好吧，那就留在聊天室里，即使你不想玩也说点垃圾话。我想我待了大约六个月。
Really? Yeah, you were in there. You were in there. It was great. Don and Pratt and Rujo. Yeah, it was fun. It was a lot like this, just like pot shots from the side. It was a lot of pot shots. Well, you know, Will, you and Don should go out and play some golf while I'm on my golf hiatus. And then I'll rejoin you guys in the end of the photo.
真的吗？是的，你在里面。你在里面。那太棒了。唐、普拉特和鲁乔。是的，很有趣。这很像现在这样，只是侧面的冷枪。有很多冷枪。好吧，你知道，威尔，你和唐应该出去打几场高尔夫，趁我还在高尔夫休赛期。然后我会在照片的最后加入你们。
Why are you on a hiatus? He's on a hiatus because he's working. He shot an even par 70 two weeks ago. Who cares really? It's not a big deal. But listen, thank you for joining us today, Don. Don, will you make me this pledge when you come back that you and I will play?
你为什么在休赛期？他在休赛期是因为他在工作。他两周前打出了平标准杆70杆的成绩。谁在乎呢？这不是什么大不了的事。但听着，谢谢你今天加入我们，唐。唐，当你回来时，你能向我保证你和我一起打球吗？
Can we do that? Can we say that'll happen? 100%. Okay, great. He's the absolute greatest. Sean, do you play? This should be the foursome. I always say I can drive the cart.
我们能做到吗？我们能说这会发生吗？100%。好的，太棒了。他是绝对最棒的。肖恩，你打球吗？这应该是四人组。我总是说我可以开车。
He loves to drive the cart. It's a date. It's so much fun. We get him a soda, we get him like a float, like a root beer float, and he drives the cart. No, Donnie, next time you're... A soda. Sometimes it's surely tipple, but it's a lot of sugar.
他喜欢开车。这是一个约会。太有趣了。我们给他买杯苏打水，给他买个漂浮饮料，比如根汁汽水漂浮，然后他开车。不，唐尼，下次你……苏打水。有时是雪莉·邓普，但糖分太多了。
It's a lot. He's very groggy, and by the the 17th hole he's kind of irritable. A little, a little, a little grump. Guys, it's good, just pick it up, we gotta go. That's totally me. Love you, Don, thank you for saying yes. Love you, pal. Enjoy the rest of your day down there in Atlanta
太多了。他很昏昏沉沉，到了第17洞他有点易怒。有点，有点，有点脾气。伙计们，好了，捡起来，我们得走了。那完全是我。爱你，唐，谢谢你答应。爱你，伙计。在亚特兰大享受你剩下的时光吧，
and say hi to our friend Mr. Heart, please. I will, thanks guys, great seeing you today. Great to see you, dude. Thank you, Don. Bye, buddy. Yep, yep. I love Don Shallant, it's so good. JB, what a great, great guest.
请代我向我们的朋友哈特先生问好。我会的，谢谢伙计们，今天见到你们很高兴。很高兴见到你，伙计。谢谢你，唐。再见，伙计。是的，是的。我爱唐·沙兰特，太棒了。JB，真是个非常非常棒的嘉宾。
God, he's so good, I love that dude. Doesn't your shoulders just drop when you're talking to him? Yes. Yeah, he's cool. I mean, he's just, I can't even form a word. Mega talent, he falls into that category. Mega talent.
天哪，他太棒了，我爱那个家伙。当你和他交谈时，你的肩膀难道不会放松下来吗？是的。是的，他很酷。我的意思是，他只是，我甚至无法形成一个词。超级天才，他属于那一类。超级天才。
And universally loved. And, yeah, we say this all the time, it seems like the people who work all the time also have wonderful personalities. Yeah, I agree. Like behind and generous. Well, Jamie, you know, you're a director, it's a big part of your career now and your life,
而且受到普遍喜爱。而且，是的，我们一直这么说，似乎那些一直工作的人也有很棒的个性。是的，我同意。比如在背后和慷慨。好吧，杰米，你知道，你是一名导演，这是你职业生涯和生活中很重要的一部分，
and when you're deciding between, you have a lot of options to do stuff with a lot of different people. And part of the calculus, I imagine, is who do I want to spend the next four months with? Yeah, for sure. It's huge, and it's before I even start to get excited about the idea of them coming on.
当你决定时，你有许多选择可以和许多不同的人一起做事情。我想，计算的一部分是我想和谁一起度过接下来的四个月？是的，当然。这很重要，甚至在我开始对他们加入的想法感到兴奋之前。
And that's cast or crew. I'll do Zooms with people that I may not even see on the set. And I just need to know that they're not going to wreck it with their not being nice people. It's important. But he is amazing. And I could have just gone on forever and ever.
那是演员或剧组。我会和那些我甚至可能在片场见不到的人进行Zoom会议。我只需要知道他们不会因为不是好人而毁掉它。这很重要。但他太棒了。我本可以永远聊下去。
We didn't get to much of anything, which is what we do on this show. Sorry listeners. You know, we get a lot of complaints about that. I think that some, from some people who say like, oh you guys didn't, you just, and what they forget is like, we're just so excited to see Don, right?
我们什么都没聊到，这就是我们在节目里做的。抱歉听众们。你知道，我们收到了很多关于此的抱怨。我想有些人说，哦，你们没有，你们只是，而他们忘记的是，我们只是太高兴见到唐了，对吧？
So I got like Don, so we just start talking. Yeah, we're not journalists. We're just three dummies that wanna just talk a little bit and can't believe anyone's listening. So yeah. If you're like, oh, why didn't you get to what Don's favorite dog type is, we're like, sorry. We just want to talk shit with him. Yeah.
所以我得到了唐，所以我们只是开始聊天。是的，我们不是记者。我们只是三个想聊聊天的傻瓜，不敢相信有人在听。所以是的。如果你说，哦，为什么你们没聊唐最喜欢的狗的品种，我们会说，抱歉。我们只是想和他聊聊垃圾话。是的。
You know what I mean? That's on the Smartless Extras, if you want to know his favorite dog type. Exactly. Or talk about like vacation spots, like, I don't know, like, has he ever been to Thailand? Or Mumbai? Or like... Mumbai!
你知道我的意思吗？如果你想知道他最喜欢的狗的品种，那就在Smartless Extras里。完全正确。或者聊聊度假胜地，比如，我不知道，比如，他去过泰国吗？或者孟买？或者像……孟买！
Mumbai! Mumbai! You glaze right over it, Mumbai! Yeah. Yeah. Smart. Smart. Smart.
孟买！孟买！你直接略过了，孟买！是的。是的。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry. If you like SmartList, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。Smartless是由Rob Armgerve、Bennett Barbico和Michael Grant Terry手工制作的100%有机节目。如果你喜欢SmartList，你可以通过在Wondry应用程序或Apple播客上加入Wondry Plus，现在就提前收听无广告版本。
Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. Are you looking to add a new podcast to your ever-growing podcast schedule? If the answer to that question is yes, or even if it's maybe, or really anything other than a hard no, let me suggest my podcast, Life is Short with Justin Long. In every episode we peek inside the heads of actors, musicians, authors, and thinkers to find out what makes them tick and how they find meaning in life. I'm also very curious about some of the heavier, more existential stuff like what emoji they
Prime会员可以在Amazon Music上收听无广告版本。在你离开之前，请在Wondry.com/survey填写一份简短的调查问卷，告诉我们关于你的信息。你是否正在寻找在不断增长的播客时间表中添加一个新的播客？如果这个问题的答案是肯定的，或者甚至是可能的，或者真的除了坚决拒绝之外的任何答案，让我推荐我的播客，Justin Long的《Life is Short》。在每一集中，我们都会窥探演员、音乐家、作家和思想家的内心，找出是什么让他们动心，以及他们如何在生活中找到意义。我也对一些更沉重、更存在主义的东西感到好奇，比如他们最常使用什么表情符号，
use most often and what their favorite form of a potato is, you know, the important stuff. So join us because, you know, life is short. If you like Life is Short and Life is Shorter, you can listen ad-free right now by joining Wondery Plus in the Wondery app or on Apple Podcasts. Prime members can listen ad-free on Amazon Music. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及他们最喜欢的土豆形式是什么，你知道，重要的事情。所以加入我们，因为，你知道，人生苦短。如果你喜欢《Life is Short》和《Life is Shorter》，你可以通过在Wondery应用程序或Apple播客上加入Wondery Plus，现在就收听无广告版本。Prime会员可以在Amazon Music上收听无广告版本。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。